Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 24
2016 Oh,
we're getting down to it.
Ah,
those little kids are going to be coming by for the candy,
right?
Oh,
those cute little kids see up cute until they're about seven and then they start
thinking they know shit.
Right.
And then they fucking start showing up.
I swear to God,
you know,
if they're almost eye level,
you ought to be able to just get the fuck outta here.
Go Buy your own guy.
Didn't get enough.
Get a fucking paper route.
You bump right.
The first hour,
hour and a half of Halloween is great.
The kids are so fucking cute.
The parents are all excited.
It's really what it is.
Like the cutoff for fucking Halloween should be roughly about eight years old
and then everybody else should just go fuck off.
Go put your fucking,
you know,
but your virtual reality glasses on and get,
go shoot a bunch of people.
Whatever it is.
These,
these,
these kids do now a days,
I don't pretend to understand.
You know,
I understand they can't go outside.
You can't put,
send them outside because you know there's,
there's a pervert behind every fucking tree evidently.
So don't,
don't have 'em outside.
Have him inside,
put on some virtual reality glasses and let them just walk around in this world,
you know,
just shooting up people where they're nice and safe.
Right.
Um,
I dunno,
I was just reading this,
there was this psychology magazine that I picked up,
um,
during this fucking unbelievable ride back I had from Nashville and it was all
about a narcissism and that type of stuff and just how easily that word is
thrown around now,
how everybody,
you know,
who isn't a psychologist and myself included somehow that word like hit the
mainstream,
I don't know when
it's been around my whole life.
I think the article said sometime in the early seventies,
and then every bow,
this person's no narcissist,
narcissistic Blahblahblahblahblah and I guess it actually true narcissists,
it only affects a really small portion of the,
of,
uh,
the population.
And they would just talking about,
there's different kinds of it.
Like everybody thinks it's the person taking a selfie.
It isn't necessarily that person.
Some,
it could be a total fucking narcissist,
but like goes the other way.
And uh,
it was really like depressed and withdrawn and all that.
And basically,
uh,
their pain and all of that becomes their narcissism.
Just fucking sitting around talking about,
oh,
I don't know how miserable they are.
I have no fucking idea.
All I know is I read it and I was just going,
yeah,
I do that.
Oh,
I do that too.
That's what I remember.
I breached shit on fucking Psychos,
narcissist fucking lunatics,
whatever the hell it is.
You know,
it's like,
it's,
you know what it's like,
it's like reading a fucking horoscope.
I swear to God.
You know,
when you sit there,
and I've always maintained people who are into astrology.
You always go,
you believe in that shit.
I believe in that shit.
And if you've got the fucking paper,
just say,
well,
when you're bored,
I was born on May,
may the sixth.
Oh,
you're a fucking a,
you're a Taurus.
Right?
And then go read the fucking Gemini or
the Sagittarius.
Oh,
the fucking Blue Bonnet bowl.
Whatever the fuck sign they are.
You just read that one instead and you watched him devoloped all the,
I know it.
I know exactly.
Yeah.
Did need the back burner.
Yeah,
that was
timber.
So you know it's people like,
why can't you just send me believe what I want to believe.
So I'm actually recording this Sunday night.
I was going to record it tomorrow morning,
but my lovely,
beautiful,
gorgeous wife is upstairs and do you know what she still,
when she's watching the reality fucking shows and I sit there,
I try to hang in there.
I fucking try to hang in there.
I can't fucking do it.
It's,
it's like,
it's so fucking depressing.
I don't understand how she and Michael Rappaport can watch that fucking shit.
It's just,
it's,
it's fucking,
she's watching one right now.
All they do,
they just sit around talking about stuff,
bags and shoes.
And this one wants Teddy's because her sister's got bigger titties.
I wish I had tits like you until they get sick.
These are like,
yeah,
they stay,
don't do anything.
And then there are always going on vacation to clear their head from doing
nothing,
I guess being on the show and haven't been in front of the cameras and stuff.
Yeah,
I guess that would get fucking annoying after awhile.
But they don't fucking do anything.
And then there's this guy with a beard and he comes walking in and he's always
acting like he's fucking got all these businesses going.
He's not fucking doing anything either.
I can,
they do the shelf.
That's what the fuck they do.
And uh,
so I'm hanging in there and I'm trying to watch,
I'm trying to watch and then they do that horror.
Like you watched them talk about the shit and then they cut to the people who
you just saw talking about the shit.
Then they talk about the,
they just talk about what they just did.
So
the one on one wants to get a fucking boob job.
Okay.
And they,
they probably just had her do it,
you know,
just so they can get a fucking episode out of it.
All I know is been the end when she goes to talk about it.
This is what I tapped out after listening to these fucking people sitting around
talking about themselves,
you know,
and just walking around with these fucking $10,000 worth of clothes to walk into
a fucking living room and sit down and talk about other clothes.
Right?
They cut to the one who was going to get a titties done and she sits down in the
first,
soon as she comes out of her mouth,
she just goes for me.
And I was just like,
I'm a,
I get to get the fuck outta here.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
I can't like,
what do you mean for me?
We just listened to you talk about it.
Like they should just want it.
They should just go down to a fucking soup kitchen,
go late,
allowed some shit for a while.
I don't know the names,
just talk about how fucking,
um,
we still on
making Camino,
all the different people and is it,
they're just like really,
really poor.
And I just,
just,
it just,
I just,
for me,
it was just so great to connect with you
float.
And they would be doing that in full on fucking makeup with love bracelets going
all the way up to their fucking Goddamn neck.
And I don't know,
just after helping people like that,
I just really feel like I need to clear my head and go to San Louis Obispo,
whatever the fuck
those goddamn people go.
Jesus Christ.
I just,
uh,
I don't know why she watches it.
Why does she watch it?
She likes grape movies.
She's a very smart pride.
I don't know,
I guess,
you know,
for me,
I guess I watched fucking football,
you know,
that's just as fucking stupid.
I watched people sitting there talking about,
I guess,
I guess that's the female version of it and I have to accept that's the fucking
fact.
And that,
um,
we are staying in this fucking house right now and,
uh,
you know what's,
you know,
what's going on with this house.
We thought this fucking creepy ass house was haunted.
All right.
We looked at it during the day,
during the day.
Look great at night.
It feels like there's somebody fucking watching you and you're hearing all these
weird sounds and everything.
And uh,
you know,
I kind of figured out,
we kind of figured out what it is.
There's a,
there's rodents in the walls of this place,
like a lot of old houses.
If you have an old fucking house,
um,
you know,
there's inroads there like,
if you lived in buffalo and you bought an old house,
would it really surprise you if there was some prohibition error tunnel
underneath your fucking house?
I mean,
you know,
the Capone fucking characters were there,
right across the river was Canada.
They bring the fucking booze and allowed here you got all these fucking old ass
houses,
mine included,
which by the way,
I just went over there to see what the fuck they were
and trying to rewire the thing so I won't blow up my house someday.
And they told me they were done with the wiring and I was all excited and I
gloated that there was no more fucking cloth wiring and the Goddamn House.
And I went on and I look at me now,
I'm talking about my stuff.
Um,
I go to turn the fucking light on,
turn the light on,
and they go,
what do you call it?
The fucking lights that are on the wall.
They're not under the ceiling,
right.
Whatever the fuck you call it.
It's fucking sitting there.
Right.
And I turned on the light and it just go,
I see this spark just go like right up the side and landed on the dog bed and I
just shut it off.
I was like,
hi,
I'm going to bring that up tomorrow.
But,
uh,
no.
I got in there and they got the floor and now they're starting to build the
cabinet.
So I'm seeing the fucking light at the end of the tunnel here.
So,
uh,
you know,
I'll tell you the cloth wiring never did that,
but once we get this done,
then the fucking houses,
it's done.
It's fucking done.
And I can just live there quietly and just,
you know,
stare at the fucking wall and know that there's no more squirrels there,
like this fucking place.
I don't know what the fuck are in the walls.
I told him that story I told you a few weeks ago about,
I was over at a buddy's house and there was a mouse in the house that was this
house.
And the reason why I said it was a friend of mine's house,
because I didn't want to tell my wife that there was a fucking rodent in the
goddamn house because then she'd be freaking the fuck out and I'd have to deal
with that shit.
All right.
Um,
but my father in law was over.
It was three leaks.
Weeks later we had a couple of beers.
It was a funny story and I just find,
just said,
you know,
I,
my wife brought up that it was haunted and I finally just said,
no,
honey,
it's not on it.
There's fucking rodents.
Okay.
And,
and in,
in the walls,
I just heard one came walking by and I heard a bunch of shit fall down the
plaster.
And I know that's what it is because when I was a kid,
we had that problem in our house.
And I remember we had these squirrels were in the fucking walls.
I don't know how they got in there,
but they were fucking in there.
And uh,
so we somehow cornered one.
Okay.
It was behind the cabinets and there was like a whole,
like not buying the kit,
like it was in the wall behind the cabinet.
So all I remember was I had like this mop handle and I'm fucking,
you know,
Randall in it in the hall is my dad had this,
do you know the fucking giant butcher knife trying to find this fucking thing
and uh,
okay,
he's fucking jabbing the knife and the whole,
and I got the fucking mob panel go and try to flush this thing out.
All the sudden this fucking thing,
like a rocket runs out of the hole right up to the fucking mop,
handle up my arm,
jumps on my shoulder and just leaps off.
And I do,
I was just like,
dude,
the fucking thing.
And it had nowhere to go and my dad cornered it and he finished the fucking
thing off.
You know,
that's,
it was,
this is before Peter,
you know,
now I guess we would have been,
accused of some sort of hate crime against a squirrels.
I have no idea of when my dad finished the fucking thing off and um,
you know,
we dealt with that.
There was bats in the fucking anything.
You know,
when there was an old house,
the house was older than the house then,
well I guess it was made earlier.
I don't think it was older.
It was like seven years old.
Mines fucking 90.
Anyways,
these old fucking houses,
it's just,
you're going to have guests.
All right.
I'm not a big ghost guide.
Like I,
I always think it's Rodin's first and I don't know,
these fucking things are all over the God damn place.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I,
you know,
at least I can say that about my fucking piece of shit of a house,
at least what I don't have,
I don't have squirrels in the walls,
you know,
I mean you,
you turn the fucking light on.
I mean,
I'm not saying a spark won't come out and singe off half your fucking mustache
at this point,
but you know,
if you know it did.
So it's a process.
That's what it is.
All right.
So anyways,
as you guys might,
I was taping a standup special,
uh,
on Friday at the Ryman and,
I did it,
it went great.
Uh,
now I have the horrible thing where I have to go back and look at myself.
which is not something I,
I dunno,
it's the weirdest thing.
Like if I,
if I just take a set and I'm just going to watch it,
I can look at it,
but if I know that this is going to go onto Netflix and that the general public,
if they want to,
can look at it,
then just,
then every fucking thing that I hate about myself,
it's just like sticking out like a sore thumb.
So I'm going to have to try to plow my way through this as quickly as possible.
But,
uh,
the shows went great.
It was such an amazing night.
And,
um,
I got to tell you,
you know,
if I don't sound excited is it's kind of like a let down a couple of days later,
cause now I have no fucking act.
And uh,
I had such a good time and it was so weird,
like coming up to that,
I was like,
oh my God,
I'm so sick of these fucking jokes.
Um,
I got to record these and move on because I'm past these jokes.
And then that night I was doing and I was having so much fun when the night was
over,
I was like,
oh my God,
I don't get to do this bit anymore.
I don't get to do that bit anymore.
Um,
I guess I can for the next couple of months before the thing comes out.
But,
uh,
now the one in the can and another one in the can't,
Joe Barden and killed,
um,
it's going to be cool.
I think we're going to have a,
hopefully have a nice look to it.
Uh,
I dunno,
I already looked at some pictures of it and I,
you know,
I'm already just going like,
oh,
what did I do this?
What did I do that?
But I think,
I think it looks good.
I fucking hate this.
This is the,
this is the worst part of it.
It's the worst part of it.
I wish I could just take a fucking drug that would make me forget that I was
watching myself and I could just sit down and be like,
okay,
this is somebody else's special.
Put this here,
put that day,
Big Bang,
boom,
and it's done.
Then I could fucking walk away from itself.
Um,
I dunno.
That's the only thing I don't like about it.
But other than that,
it went fucking great.
So listen to this shit.
So I,
um,
oh,
and thank you for everybody who came out to,
uh,
it really was an incredible,
incredible night.
Um,
yeah,
it was,
it was fucking awesome.
And now I'm just sitting in the basement of this fucking rat infested fucking
house.
Um,
I,
my,
my year was done.
I got nothing to do.
I get comics come home.
Is My last thing.
And then I'm just fucking in town because I've been out of town all year and,
uh,
we got to finish an editing.
F is for family and uh,
you know,
I feel,
I feel like,
hey,
there's the lovely Nia.
What are,
you know,
um,
so I'm going to tell him the story here.
Do you want to jump on
a,
um,
I'm going to tell them the story.
That flight
that I had,
he wanted me to,
I'll hit pause here if you want to grab a mic.
Okay.
Well,
do people really want to listen to you unwrapping that shit?
All right,
I'll tell you story.
So anyways,
so
nia was supposed to come out and see me.
Right.
And then for whatever reason,
you weren't able to make it out right.
For whatever reason.
Yeah.
Whatever reason,
the doctor said you're not allowed to fly
and your current condition.
Yes.
So I'm like,
all right,
I guess I'm out there by myself.
And,
uh,
so I was gonna,
I was gonna hang out with her on Saturday,
you know,
go around doing all the dumb shit,
you know?
Yeah.
We were going to get barbecue and then we're going to go to that fucking
restaurant that every fucking person goes to.
That was in that show Nashville that you loved.
All right.
The Bluebird cafe.
We're going to do all of that shit.
And then at night I was either going to go to the penguins,
a predators game or I was going to go to the Vanderbilt football game.
Um,
but you weren't allowed to go.
So,
uh,
I said,
fuck it.
I'll come back Saturday or as they say in Boston,
say right.
So I had a,
hang on,
let me turn your fucking mic on him.
You good?
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm able just to put the thing together like I know how to do it now.
Yes,
you do.
What I didn't like is that you've been driving that wonderful car that I got you
for a year
and you've never checked the oil or had anybody check it.
I thought you knew to do that too,
at least.
I mean,
I think I knew in,
in like as a general concepts that that's a thing that needs to happen.
But,
but yeah,
thank you.
But,
um,
as a concept,
this is the thing that I didn't know shit about cars or engines.
Really.
I just contact,
I knew that you had to do a,
but I just,
I just went on Youtube.
I went on Youtube.
How does an engine work?
I just started with that and then I,
I got all the way up to like,
you know,
I started watching gas monkey.
I started watching Eric,
the car guy,
Eric the car guys.
Great.
And you just learn Eric,
the car guy,
you'll even learn about electrical.
I mean that guy fucking knows everything and like you can,
uh,
you know,
get your head around what's going on underneath the hood.
It all needs to stay lubricated and it needs to stay cool.
Those are the two big things.
Cool.
And lubricate it.
It lubricated.
If it gets too hot,
the block could crack,
you know?
Oh,
the fucking,
the Pistons and everything,
you literally just seize up the engine.
Okay.
So you haven't put a lot of miles on it.
So here's the thing.
So I,
I go out there and I'm going to show her,
you know,
I'm going to show her how to check the oil,
right.
So I go into the cockpit of this fucking thing and I'm trying,
then it's not even labeled where to do.
And I finally find the piece of plastic because you don't want to tug too hard
on any,
but some of it's just parts that come apart,
you know?
And then there's like the fuses underneath there.
And so I finally find it,
I popped the hood and I clearly see where you put the oil in.
And for the life of me,
I cannot find any dipstick anywhere.
And I'm like,
where the fuck does,
is it,
where the fuck is it?
Where the fuck is it?
And I finally googled,
you know,
you're making model whereas the dipstick and it's just,
it's all on the dashboard now.
Yeah,
it's going to,
if you're low on oil,
it's going to tell you,
which I guess is more convenient or whatever.
But,
um,
I dunno,
I get told me that my tire pressure was too low,
but I get nervous as far as like,
if that fucks up,
like,
yeah,
the dipstick is great.
You stick it in there.
Well actually you pull it out,
your wipe it off first.
That's what I was doing.
And you stick it in,
you pull it out and it'll show you if you need,
you know,
ad it'll say fallen.
And there's this little round thing where you're going too high and you have too
much oil.
Little round us are a little circles.
They st Lou shape the circle.
That was it.
And it's just not fucking there.
So anyways,
let me tell you,
so leave a Nashville Seigel right.
You know,
she can't fly out.
So I'm gonna I'll fly back Saturday and I'll hang out with that.
Right.
So,
uh,
I go over the year port,
I get there nice and early.
I drop off the car,
the rental car,
Amal Zippity Doo Dah,
because I'm nice and early and I get all the way to the gate long ass fucking
walk.
And I realized that I didn't,
you know,
I didn't give the car keys to the people there at budget and Mike are fuck.
So I had to walk all the way back.
I wasn't on the other side of security.
I just walked all the way back and then I came as an like thinking in my head
seed.
This is why I leave plenty of time.
I'm not losing my temper.
Everything's fucking fine.
This is the new bill,
right?
I'm not going to be the new bill.
I'm not going to be me.
I'm trying to find the humor in.
Thanks.
Okay.
All right.
Like I had my checks from my gigs this week.
I go down to the bank tonight cause I don't want to deal with the cluster fuck
of the bank during the day with a bunch of people who don't understand how to
handle their money.
Their money is fucked up and you're standing behind them in line and it takes
for fucking ever and they're always yelling through the bulletproof glass at the
other person is if that person went out and bought too much shiny shit with
their money.
Basically speaking.
All right,
I'm not talking about that.
Wells Fargo crap with those cuts.
What they did and then they paid off those 5,000 people.
It's like,
all right,
get the fuck outta here.
Here's a little confidentiality agreement.
You guys all collectively yet individually came up with this fucking scam.
It wasn't me.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
So I went down and I go down to the bank and,
and it takes,
you know,
I had like three checks.
It takes two,
one a three and it won't take the last one.
And I started to lose it.
I distinctly remember slapping the ATM machine and hearing my wedding band ring
when I did it.
And I was just like,
I went up to eight,
eight for me,
12 for any other normal person,
but it was an aid for me and I was like,
Bill,
just fucking relax.
It's all fine.
And I thought about my flight and what the fuck happens.
And I was just like,
this is really pales in comparison.
So here's what happened,
my flight.
So I get on this fucking flight,
right?
Sitting up their first fall can glaze right.
Very quickly,
but I have distressful for his class seat.
It's the fucking front row.
So you get the bulkhead in front of you,
which means there's,
I always just have a backpack and I was shove it underneath the seat.
So I get on the plane fucking relaxed.
I don't have to worry about overhead space is somebody shoves 15 coats up there
in a child seat,
you know.
But uh,
I had the stress because,
you know,
I didn't have the fucking thing in front of me.
So that was once I got past that stress,
I sat down,
it's all fucking good and we're flying back and all I'm thinking is,
Oh fuck man,
I'm getting back.
It's fucking football Sunday.
Tomorrow I'm going to watch the,
uh,
the fucking,
the,
the Formula One race.
You know,
I'm going to watch the Patriots game.
I'm going to maybe watch a little buffalo,
Miami,
you know,
I got the whole fucking,
I got my whole thing laid out right?
Maybe catch a lake college game shit out.
By the time I land,
it's only gonna be like eight o'clock at night.
So we fucking go up in the year,
we're about 45 minutes into the flight and I start smelling what smells like
burnt popcorn.
That's the smell first.
And then it gets a little more fucking intense and I'm kind of looking at the
stewardess is hit,
I'm in the first fucking row gone.
Did one of them burn a meal.
Like I'm smelling a burning smell and it's starting to fuck with my eyes a
little bit and I'm not seeing any panic on their faces.
So I go,
it must be food because I know I only have a few hours flying with my license,
but I know,
you know,
smoke in the plane is not,
it's not a good thing right now.
So everything's going about normally and then all of a sudden I feel as
descending,
you know,
and I feel like the fucking wings are doing little more doing that shit and I'm
like,
Oh wow,
we must be hitting some rough,
fair cause then the smoke wasn't as bad and I was thinking like we must be
hidden.
It wasn't like visible smoke.
You could smell it and I could kind of feel it my eyes a little bit.
Um,
how old did I just say I could smell it.
I felt it in my eyes.
It was very uncomfortable.
Um,
so the fucking wings,
I like doing that shit and I'm thinking like,
oh he probably got it.
They know a report that there was some rough air up and he's going to go
underneath and then we'll go back up again.
And then like all of a sudden my glass with the water started sliding forward.
Like all of a sudden I was kind of realizing that my chair was kind of,
we were at like a fun,
like not a 45 degree angle,
but we were at a significant,
we would fucking descending rapidly in all of a sudden the stewards just came
up,
she goes,
can I take your glasses?
Were landing.
And then I was just like,
oh fuck,
something's on fire.
And the pilot didn't give any like announcement like no,
cause we were like at 30 something thousand feet in the second you smoke.
It's like,
I don't know I there,
I guarantee you there were lights lighting up on his little dashboard there and
it wasn't saying check the tire pressure.
I don't know what warning lights they have probably didn't want to make,
he didn't want anyone to panic.
So he's just like,
you know what,
let me just land this thing.
No,
I think he smelled smoke like there's something on fire and I'm 30,000 feet and
I have to get this thing on the fucking ground immediately.
And he didn't say anything because of wasn't they normally tell you like we are
going to like the sand really quickly because of this,
that and the I,
I had nothing to do with scaring us and that he didn't have fucking time.
Okay.
So he just fucking goes down and I'm just like,
Oh shit,
here we go.
Right.
So the late late this stewardess,
you know,
I didn't know we were landing cause they had,
everybody had the shades pulled down and it wasn't until my glass fucking slid
forward,
I was like,
this guy's like,
sky's really,
he's really dropping down here like what's going on?
And what's,
so when she came over and she said,
hey,
we're,
we're landing now,
right?
We're literally 15 minutes in the flight,
Nashville to La,
right?
The woman next to me,
he goes like,
oh my God,
we're here already.
And I was like,
I laughed.
no,
no.
I go,
we're landing.
She goes,
where?
And I said,
well,
I looked at my watch and go,
I dunno,
she fucking lifted up to shade.
I saw a river.
I go,
maybe that's the Mississippi,
I'm going to say Saint Louis.
It turned out it was a little rock,
Arkansas.
And,
uh,
she goes,
well,
why are we landing?
And I was like,
well,
it probably had to do with that.
Did you smell that burning smell?
She was like,
yeah,
I go,
probably has to do with that.
And uh,
so she's looking around and go,
yeah,
but he really has,
he had total control of the airplane.
But my thing that I was worried with about is,
you know,
I don't know about the mechanics on planes and shit,
but like if there was some sort of something,
whatever,
it burned through some wire,
some hydraulic thing,
and all of a sudden he can't control it.
And next thing you know,
we're upside down.
Like in that Denzel movie,
you know?
Yeah.
When you lose the rear stabilizer,
the dumbest shit ever that he's able to flip it back over and land,
you know,
um,
Hollywood movie.
Yeah.
He wants,
it's up like you fucked.
Nobody can land that.
Not even Salie.
Right.
So we start fucking coming in and we're in little rock.
I don't know,
it's little rocket.
All he sees is fucking river.
And you know,
those things,
you can only see out the side.
And I'm just thinking,
get it on the ground,
get it on the ground.
Just get it on the fucking ground.
And,
uh,
all I'm seeing is this fucking,
that's the,
uh,
that's the rodents in the wall.
There's one,
there's one like right above your fucking heads or ran by,
I think it's a quarter.
The,
I don't know if you guys can't hear it,
you just hear a plaster falling.
I think they ate through the air condition duck and they just sort of run back
and forth,
you know?
Okay.
All right.
So anyway,
so I'm,
I'm almost dying in a plane crush in here.
So the fucking thing comes down.
All in,
all I see is the,
uh,
the river and,
and that's what I started thinking of like it,
this mother fucker puts this thing in the water.
All right.
All I'm thinking is,
is stay conscious.
You have to fucking stay conscious and a,
that fucking doors right around the corner provided,
you know,
he doesn't smash the whole thing up and you can't open the door.
And then I got to fight my way through all these other fuckers and I'm going to
drown.
But then I see the runway,
he lands the thing and then just like,
please reverse engineer reverse engines though,
since kicked in.
Then once we stopped,
I was like,
okay,
all right,
fine.
I live right.
So we go over,
we taxi over,
there's a fire engine,
one of those and there's only one,
cause it's little rock,
Arkansas,
right?
It's a little fucking fire engine comes over.
We go to deep plane like do you need tea,
plane?
And there was smoke Baba Bell,
the captain came on and he finally says,
he said,
I had my hands full up,
hear me.
Uh,
sorry,
I didn't make an announcement,
meaning like it was a serious fucking thing.
Um,
so I,
as we got to get off this,
two guys in the giant fucking speced his suits,
they look ridiculous.
They look like they were beekeepers.
It is,
they didn't look like firefighters.
And we go to get off and um,
as we get off,
you know,
the ticket agent person,
okay,
they're going to check to see if the plane is still fine and blah,
blah blah.
And I love thinking in my head is like,
dude,
the fucking thing was on fire fired.
There's no fucking way we're getting back on that.
There's people walking in with the beekeeper super suits.
It's over,
right?
So we sit there for about a half an hour and uh,
they finally come on.
They say,
hey,
here's the deal.
We need to get a new plane.
The plane they were going to get is two hours away,
but the crew is an hour away from getting to the plane.
So it's going to be about a three hour delay and you people will kind of cool.
But there's all those,
you know,
the 15% wow.
Look,
they're
giving them shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
Giving them shit.
It's like,
dude,
the fucking thing,
I dunno what was on fire,
what was smoldering,
but it was smoldering at 30 something thousand feet and the fucking pilot just
got us on the ground and we like a stud and we didn't die and now you're fucking
bitching,
man.
Go Up to the bar and shut the fuck up.
Right.
So there's one guy there with his purple shirt and he's fucking breaking his
neck,
shaking his head like I was fumbling.
And you know the deal,
you know,
you know the deal.
If they say it's going to happen in three hours,
that means about what's going to be about 12 right?
So we go into the bar and I want you Auburn kicking the shit out of the
razorbacks.
Then I watched the cubs get into the world series and they just keep going like,
well it's not,
now it's looking like nine 30 and then they do that.
It's looking like 10,
10 we're thinking 10 46 and people just eat more,
Ahh,
ahh,
freaking out.
Then they changed the gate and everybody just is gradually more and more like
And then they're vacuuming up the airport.
It was the Hillary and Bill Clinton airport,
the bill and Hillary Clinton airport,
which was,
you know,
it would basic seats,
the Clintons,
they stole so much money.
There's only so much left for the airport there.
Right.
So long story short,
we landed about four o'clock,
this are our five o'clock or something like that.
The plane,
we didn't get on the fucking plane to get out of there until like,
uh,
like a little bit after 1:00 AM.
And this is the thing,
like the lady,
the person goes,
okay,
so the planes here and then every,
it's like,
so it's going to take us to la now and the person,
the guy just goes like,
ah,
no,
the plane's going to take you back to Dallas.
Yeah.
Everyone's like,
Dallas,
we came from Nashville.
Listen,
what kind of ways is to run an airline?
They're like screaming it.
This Guy Ed.
Uh,
and I wish I sat the whole time.
I just sat there laughing my ass off going like,
who gives a fuck?
As long as we were not dead,
right?
Like I just couldn't like that man.
It was fucking scary,
right?
So they end up flying us into Dallas and uh,
we'd land and we're like,
this is the plane would take an la,
right?
They're like,
absolutely.
We land in that in Dallas.
And they go,
okay,
we're going to need everybody to get off the plane.
Right?
There's one guy here,
this guy,
they can't possibly think we're ever going to fly this airline again.
Right.
I'm like,
I'm absolutely gonna fly it again.
One of the guys who works for them just flew a plane that was somehow on fire
from 30,000 fucking feet down to the ground.
Said great airline.
It's a great fucking airline.
So we get off the fucking plane and I slept on the fucking floor waiting for the
get back on and we ended up getting back on.
And uh,
we ended up landing at like,
I think like 10 in the morning and actually figured it out.
We took 16 hours for me to get back from Nashville and from here to Sydney.
Australia is 14 hours.
So I literally could have flown to Sydney,
got a connecting flight,
got my ass down to Melbourne.
But you know what Nia,
I didn't fucking,
I didn't burn up in a plane.
That's all.
I just kept thinking
you,
the fact that you did in flip out,
it's still like kind of amazing to me.
But the thing is with you is that when big things like this happen,
you are so calm.
Like you are just very like relaxed and you have like a lot of perspective about
it and you're like,
well,
but this and this and this,
so this and this and this.
But like,
you know,
God forbid there's a new operating system on your phone.
It's like you have the meltdown of like,
you know,
I would put everybody in your crash.
Everybody who flipped out about all of that airplane shit,
I would've put all of them to shame over new operating system on your phone.
I can,
I can lose it.
I can sit for 16 hours in an airport.
I had a great time.
I went in and I shut down.
I watched the cubs.
Like I'm sitting there going like the little cubs literally have not been to a
world series.
They've even Ben,
there is bad as Cleveland is.
They haven't even fucking gotten to the world series in [inaudible] 71 years.
That's,
that's almost impossible.
If it wasn't them,
it is
impossible because I don't think anybody else has ever fucking done like just
not been there.
I would've been crying out of frustration.
I would have been so tired and hungry and frustrated and like all these things,
the fucking plane was on fire.
No,
I got it.
I or whatever it was smoldering.
Something was burning and everyone was sitting there going,
who had one of those fucking galaxy seven phones in there?
There,
right,
exactly.
They Namsa yeah,
that they checked.
That's what I was thinking.
Cause there was that thing with value.
Jet was something caught on fire underneath there and it burned through what it
was,
what,
it's whatever controllers they had and the thing crashed into a fucking swamp.
Did you and some of the body's got eaten by alligators.
Oh Jesus.
Did you say that?
Fuck that.
I'm sleeping on a floor.
Did you say like at the airport or somebody asks about that phone,
like they were asking people if anyone had that phone.
Oh,
well we got,
when we got back on the plane the second time they said if anybody has a galaxy
seven phone,
can you notice five?
The stewardess?
Yeah.
Um,
which is hilarious to me.
Like,
okay,
it happened on a plane.
You know that guys phones aren't smoking in his pocket.
He went to turn it off.
He put it in his pocket and then or something like that and started smoking.
Yeah,
but it's not going to take down a plane if it's in your bag and it starts
smoking and then ignites with the shirt or some shit like that and you have a
really,
I guess a bad canvas suitcase.
Why could not have happened?
It eats its way out then.
Yeah,
I think you're in Trump,
but what's,
what's he going to do?
Just stare at his pocket as it slowly catches on fire going,
oh my God,
they're all going to die.
Yeah,
I did.
That's exactly
what happened.
Dude.
There was a guy that literally tried to light his fucking shoes on fire and
everybody just beat the fuck out of him.
Like that's what,
what happened to this guy and he was trying to take the fucking plane down.
Those phones are like fuck.
They always exaggerate.
They always exaggerate like you went through,
if there's anything smoking on a plane,
on a pressurized plucking,
enclosed,
you know,
thing in Vietnam vehicle.
But you know what I'm saying?
Vessel.
Yeah.
Got to get everybody out of there.
Better safe than sorry.
I know,
but it's like you your case so your phone starts catching on fire.
It started,
I mean,
how long are you going to take it out?
Like oh my God,
what the fuck and then take your little complimentary glass of water and dump it
on it and it's over.
You know what?
I don't know what he did after that.
I,
I'm sure he took it out and was like,
oh shit,
I know exactly what it did.
He grab somebody else's phone and took a selfie and said Hashtag fuck my life.
And then he got a deal.
He got some sort of internet deal and now he makes 400 grand.
He's the fuck my life guy.
And he runs around and he does,
he does splits in front of people like to do with the blonde hair.
That fucking 60 minutes segment really chapter your ass didn't that
building?
No,
it didn't.
I,
I'm Kyle and I weighed the low back of bill and I just watched it.
60 minutes segment,
right about social media influencers.
And so there's these kids on there,
cause you know they're millennials or whatever,
what the exception of Kim Kardashians.
But the other people on there are these young people that you know,
have all these viewed vines and snapchats and everything.
And so companies are paying them and saying the amounts of money to do
advertising before.
And one of them is this blonde kid whose name I don't remember.
He's fucking hilarious.
And he does these splits in front of people,
random locations.
He's like at the
wall of China,
Eiffel Tower and everything.
And he has all these views.
So he gets,
no,
no.
I thought all those kids are funny.
What drove me nuts about it was how the reporter just couldn't get his head
around it going like,
so then you get 6 million views and people want to advertise in that and it's
like two 16 fuck head.
You're on a TV show,
there's advertising on your TV show.
The amount of viewers that you have is how much you can charge for ad space.
Why would this be?
Just couldn't get his fucking head around it.
He's explaining it to the people that are watching 60 minutes,
which are older people generally.
They have older correspondent there explaining it to our parents.
They're not explained to us.
They let them off the hook.
You're letting them off the hook.
They're not,
they're doing,
I'm telling you it wasn't doing it for like 60 70 plus year old port porter was
exactly who I am.
I'm telling you there is a reason why they're so like,
all right,
well baby baby Cobra maybe cause I get it maybe cause I get it.
Yeah,
you get like impatient with it.
That's for old people that are like,
you do have a hamburger.
I fucking have a pod,
a podcast.
It's a radio show on the Internet.
Enough people listen.
People will like advertise.
I know,
but explain that to like an,
Oh I shouldn't even say six of my dad's 65 and I think he would grasp the
concept but like think about the most older people who are not la,
New York or just not savvy about that stuff.
Like they don't get it and they probably don't necessarily the kids like that.
Oh,
and then I fucking do this and I wear a Jimmy John's shirt and he's like,
Hey,
and day and then,
and then they pay you for that.
It's like to have to fucking bands.
This guy's going to see like there's advertising at the shows.
The rolling stones have like Bud light in the background.
Right.
I know.
I just think,
I really think that they're explaining it for older people who don't understand
what it means to go viral.
They don't even know what that word means.
It's a new phenomenon for them.
They don't get it.
60 minutes is not for people.
It's a new word for what the fuck they've been doing.
Yeah.
60 minutes went viral in the 60s it was a hit show,
right.
It just wasn't viral.
It went,
there was no internet TV or wireless or whatever the fuck you call the hit TV
show,
but viral.
Do you think there was,
there was people from the 18 hundreds still alive going like,
so you're in that box
and a lot of the more people that watch it,
you make more money.
Yes.
That's exactly how that works.
Yeah,
it was fucking like,
but he sent it to every one of them.
I know every single thing,
you know,
he was explaining it for the older people at home that don't understand these
things and Kim Kardashian couldn't have broke it down any more for him and he
just couldn't get his fucking head.
He's like,
so you don't sing,
you don't dance.
She's like,
no,
I just like,
it's a lifestyle.
I'm a brand
and it's like,
dude,
you're literally interviewing around you taking the fucking time to interview
her.
She obviously has some sort of fucking clouds.
I've never seen a guy so in the eye of the storm and he's out there with like
sunglasses on,
like looking for the sun.
It's windy and a tree could hit me in the head.
I think he just couldn't get his fucking head around it.
It was driving me up the fucking wall,
drive me up the wall.
And then also like people acting like these little things where these high
concept fucking bits,
they're not that quick little fucking things like that.
Dude,
go on,
I can do the whole Batman,
Superman.
What if in four seconds?
Yeah,
of course.
Yes.
Everybody said that.
Soup man would just fuck him up.
That was it.
And then the old guy was going like,
so like that's,
that's what you think would happen.
Sorry.
That.
And when you were watching your reality show,
I tapped out when that girl finally just goes for me after she'd just been
talking about herself and then she's going to talk about herself talking about
herself.
I have no idea.
My mom was that frustrated that it affected her that way.
And I just feel like for me,
I know I really do hate that.
Just for me,
I just feel like for me,
I just feel like is not a great way to start a sentence.
You should just say,
I think I feel for all of that,
all of that reality show speak that you watch,
you know,
and that made me feel a certain kind of way,
some type of way.
It made me feel some type of way.
It's always so fucking vague,
but in some type of way never means happy.
Now why can't you just say it fucking pissed you off.
Maybe because this is a nicer way to say it,
right?
Maybe cause you don't want to get into your specific emotions so you're like,
it just had me feeling some type of way.
No,
no,
no.
There's got one woman on any of those shows that does not want to get into how
they're feeling emotionally.
That is what the entire fucking show is.
I don't know.
I think it's just the way young people are speaking now.
They don't say,
that made me frustrated or I was really angry.
No,
that was like,
that was like a,
you just say,
I'm in my feelings.
You said no,
I'm really in my feelings.
This is,
she was really in her feelings about it or I feel some type of way.
That's what people say now instead of saying,
well,
those,
those real housewives would talking like that and they're like,
they get like 20 year old kids.
Well,
because they're trying to be by the time you want.
I'm being right now,
I'm being the old guy in 60 minutes.
I just can't get my head around why anybody.
I feel some type of way instead of saying I'm up.
So no matter how great their lives are,
they're always going to yell at each other and pull each other's hair.
I'm doing that.
Yes.
Spill.
That's what the fucking show is.
And you enjoy this.
Yes,
Bill.
That's why I watch it.
All right.
Hey near.
You know what?
Fair enough.
You feel some type of way about all this shit?
Oh my God,
that guy is 60 minutes.
It was like,
I swear to God
I wanted to eat the glass.
I was drinking out of splaining to yours,
dad.
That whole concepts.
Listen,
that's what that man was doing.
Yeah.
My Dad would get it.
You'd have to be like,
yeah,
sure,
sure.
Yeah.
He wouldn't listen.
What'd you say?
Okay,
Chris.
Phil,
I'm tired.
Okay.
I don't need to hear this shit.
Oh,
I shouldn't tell this story,
but I'm gonna.
Um,
what story?
Okay.
I can't tell.
I can't tell it cause it does,
does,
does to many people I have to fucking protect.
All I can tell you is that the authority figure called the house
and said,
ah,
Shit.
And he said,
listen,
I can't prove it,
but I know your son did sun.
What's,
you know,
x,
y and Z.
Oh right.
And then dad goes,
what do you mean?
He goes,
what do you mean you can't prove it?
But you know,
he did it and he goes,
oh Christ,
I don't have time for this shit.
And he hung up.
He was the exact opposite of I'm going to get involved with the shit.
Like I really loved that response.
No,
my family,
we're all loners,
big family,
but we all just do our own shit.
And we,
I'd last thing like the same way.
I don't want to like,
like the way I've been paying for three cell phone numbers
for the labs.
I don't even realize it to do the back story.
One time I was on the fucking road and Nia calls up,
she goes,
why do you have like three different cell phone numbers with the fuck are you
live in a double life?
And I go,
I don't,
I got one.
She goes,
no,
you got three.
I got no I don't.
I got one.
She goes,
I'm looking at the bill right now.
And what it was was
it was bad and the two thousands I was like,
I was so confused.
Slash angry.
Slash annoyed slash okay,
maybe it's just not what I think it is or whatever.
But I'm like paying all the bills and you're on the road.
So I'm like going through everything and I'm like,
this mother fucker has three numbers.
Why,
why on earth would he have three phones,
three numbers?
I'd only seen one phone.
Does he have a secret phone?
Like a secret?
So I got a little flip.
Cause I know men do that.
Sometimes they have a secret little bat phone.
All right.
This is what it was.
This is what it was back in like 15 fucking years ago.
Wasn't that maybe 1212 years ago.
It was when I was with you.
I would go on the road and this is before like smartphones and all of that and
you had to get the internet and you'd,
I go to these hotels and they were charging me like 1299 a day,
1599 a day and I wasn't making shit on the road and would fucking,
it would add up and that was still back when you know you'd get sides for your
auditions emailed to you.
Then you had to go down to the fucking the thing in the lobby and isn't a center
and print it out.
So they came up with these little things.
They look like hockey pucks,
these little round things that you you to get your own Internet.
I think Bobby Kelly,
dude,
you got to get this dude right?
Yeah.
My Dad had one of the yeah,
and plug it in and it came with like a phone number or something.
Okay.
So I got one of those big explain how to do it.
I did at one time it worked.
It didn't work again.
And then I forgot about it to the point I forgot I even had it.
And then I got another one.
Hmm.
And I met that one.
I just,
you know,
after awhile I just got a smart phone and I never look at my bill.
I just look,
what does it cost?
Yeah.
So then you know,
years later,
so you've been paying for this number.
I've been paying extra $50 a month.
There's still on my bill.
What are you going to take it off then?
Yeah,
I don't want to,
I would rather pay 50 bucks a fucking month and have to sit there and I'm not
going to get said,
I can't fucking deal with calling up and going,
I need to cancel this.
I am no longer using,
that's not how it works.
So you'll go in and they,
and,
and it goes like,
um,
you know what?
It's still robot.
And then it's going like,
you know,
if you want to do this,
press one,
if you want to do that,
press two.
And you always are existing at like one and a half.
It's like a little bit three but a little bit four years,
just like operator,
operator,
press zero.
I'm sorry that doesn't fucking,
and then
the worst thing ever is you get on and you say,
yeah,
who am I speaking with?
To a William Byrd.
Yeah.
Can I get your zip code?
Can I get you?
You're fucking first gold fish's name.
Can I get this?
Can I get that?
And then you tell them what the problem is and they go,
okay,
I'm gonna have to transfer you to somebody else and my Cologne.
And they go,
okay,
who am I speaking to?
What is your zip code?
What is the name you guys like?
I just fucking told you t here I go.
I fucking told y'all that shit.
Yeah,
I don't want to deal with that shit.
See,
you'd rather continue to pay this bill for the rest of your life.
No,
I want to take them off.
Of course I'm going to take them off.
I just,
you know,
that's not my top priority.
Nia is not fucking cool.
You saw when I tried to get the NFL network,
I was on the phone for fucking 90 mother fucking minutes.
You with people in Southeast Asia.
You didn't even know what hot and I was hockey.
Yeah,
you did really good.
Oh,
very proud of you that day.
You were so calm.
You were so polite.
You didn't like freak out.
Oh,
you miss part of it when you left.
I was just like,
listen.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm not trying to be a jerk,
but like this is your second language and you don't even know what the sport is.
I'm talking,
this would be like if you called me up and I,
you know Rosetta stone,
how you speak and you,
you want to watch cricket or is that this is Joe.
Yeah,
and they would just,
she just goes,
I'm sorry,
I'm in Asia.
Is that going to be a problem?
And then I felt bad.
I'm like,
no,
it's not a prom.
You,
you know what I'm saying?
She goes,
no,
I get it.
She was actually great.
The first person was a fucking idiot.
It wasn't a fucking idiot.
He just was not a smart person.
He,
he lacked the tools for that situation.
So now I have,
I have to do it.
There's so many fucking,
if you knew the amount of fucking money that I throw away because I don't want
to deal with the infrastructure.
Right.
The amount of times I've bought a plane ticket,
okay,
I buy a fucking plane ticket and then the thing gets canceled and I don't go,
I don't call up.
I just eat the price of the ticket.
I do it to all the fucking time.
All the fucking time because I am not going to www.delta.org I'm not fucking
dude.
I'm not doing it.
Your travel person do it.
Like when I wasn't able to go to to Nashville,
I emailed her and I said,
I'm not able to go and then I'll get it know it.
I thought,
I hate that ticket.
No,
and she's like,
I'm going to cancel it.
And I said I'm going to get a note from my doctor and so maybe we'll be able to
get reimbursed.
And she was like,
yeah,
I just canceled it.
Like let me know and we'll do what we can.
I literally like,
I think I'm paying,
I paid for a hotel room Sunday night cause we were going to be there through
Sunday night.
Yeah,
in rather than just stopping at the fucking front desk and just dealing with
that.
I just leave.
You never check out.
I don't check out.
You never do like the hi,
I'm leaving.
How was your stay enjoyable?
You just fuck I leave walk.
I'm just like,
wait,
don't we have to check out?
You're like,
Eh,
don't send me a bill.
They'll figure it out.
You never take the time to check out.
There's only the only person I know that doesn't go down there and it's like,
okay,
goodbye.
I'm leaving.
Here's the key sealand.
Are you just fucking gone?
Just leave.
I've done that with like rental cars.
One time I got so shit faced so late into the night and I didn't realize that as
6:00 AM flight,
I got up and I was still drunk and I was like,
I can't fucking,
I,
I tried to drive as I can't drive and my gps wasn't working because I was in
like fucking,
you know,
elk,
deer,
fucking Montana or some shit.
I was up in Canada.
Oh dear.
You know,
yellow knife,
you know,
they have all that shit.
They're like,
they're like us.
You know,
they wiped out the Indians and then they just named shit after him to make
themselves feel better.
Right.
No,
we didn't do it like us Canadians.
Well,
like white people,
right?
Yeah.
You're not included watching Trump rally.
You're not a part of that.
So anyways,
like,
yeah,
I remember one time was,
and I just,
I gave the keys to the guy at the hotel.
I go,
Hey,
can you take that back from me up to drug gay?
I'll fucking worry about it.
I was so fucking shit faced
that liked when two weeks later they called me up going,
yeah,
where's the car?
I was sitting there and I always give a fake number,
right.
So I'm like,
what do you mean why I brought it back.
How the fuck do you get this number?
Leave me alone.
They're like,
sir,
it,
it hasn't come back yet.
I go,
I fucking,
I dropped it off.
I just kept hanging up on him and I don't know,
it was,
there was something like the third time they called,
I finally was just like started thinking.
I was just like,
wait a minute,
did I bring that back?
And I called up Versie and I was like,
firstly,
do we bring that car back?
And he was just like,
aw dude,
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Cause you know,
cause he was,
you know,
we were all pretty fucking,
we were out there and a barn and couldn't remember.
And then I was just like,
wait a minute dude.
There was a Gig I did and I gave the keys to someone at the hotel.
Who is that?
That gig?
And then we figured out that there was that Gig and then they drove down and it
was sitting there.
That costs me like 1200 bucks.
Do you realize the house we could be living in Dick,
you as no,
I do.
It is so I do.
It calls the fucking time because I don't give a shit.
I don't keep t to money.
To me is just you just writing a number on a piece of paper and it's just like,
it's just,
if you just get past the fact that it actually has value,
do you know what?
If you just listen,
you're in to be even to be saying that.
I've always been that way.
He dollars a month is a lot to a lot of people to just be throwing away,
you know what I mean?
Like that's the don't kill me because Nia,
I fucked timeout,
timeout it.
Oh fuck that Nigga.
Fuck that.
I didn't know anybody in this business.
I didn't take the safe fucking route.
Okay,
and go for the fucking,
I'm going to go do something else.
I've fought the riots.
If blow $50 a month on a number of the,
it's my fucking money.
I fight.
I don't want to fucking deal with that shit.
I tried to be in the office area.
I wore a fucking tie.
I tried to do it.
I sat in on meetings and I literally just,
all I would think about,
it's like the,
whoever was talking,
I wanted to run right at them,
dive over their shoulder right through the fucking window and nose,
dive into the fucking parking lot.
I can't live in that fucking world.
So I picked this shit.
We're 99.9% of people fail.
All right?
So I took all of my chips.
I put it on the fucking Zillion to one shot and in fucking came in and one of
the parks of my fucking business,
I don't check out.
I walk out,
I walk out.
I don't want to talk to you.
I fucking hate when I get into it.
Fucking just leave me alone.
Just leave me the fuck the anybody who's like,
hi,
can I help you?
Let me get this right and you,
you don't ever want to deal with any type of customers on medical leave me
alone.
You do what he wanted?
No,
just leave me.
I hate when I check into a hotel and then there's a phone call and you pick up.
Hello.
Oh Hey.
Hi,
Mr. Just checking to make sure everything was all right and no wrong.
This is like mud.
You Ain't room.
You hate the housekeeping service.
Turn Down Service.
You hate all of that.
Oh my God.
When I,
my last one,
like the lady was coming in,
I'm like,
she's not going to die.
Jai Ram showing I'm like,
I'm all right.
I'm a ride.
She just kept coming up
like get high here.
I feel like I paid for that fucking room.
I got the sign hanging out on the other,
swept up by,
have to have a guard out there.
He wants to be left alone
with the fuck.
What the fuck does that mean?
Is,
is everything all right with the rum?
First of all,
I'm an adult.
If there was,
yeah,
there's fun.
I'm glad you called.
There's water pouring in.
I didn't know what to do.
The fucking room is fine.
The bed is on the ground.
There's a mattress and I lie on it.
I know how to use everything in here.
That's it.
Oh,
that's it.
Whenever we go to hotels,
if we're on vacation or anything,
and I'm like,
Bill,
can you,
especially if in a foreign country,
I might bill,
can you call down and you know,
ask them if they can make reservations or whatever.
If it's like a different language bill,
always Gus,
not enough.
You're better at that stuff than I am.
I'm like,
all you have to do is ask them to do something.
And he's like,
no,
I can't.
You have to do,
I'm not good with it.
I'm not good at
it was funny.
I actually,
well,
I got to Nashville so early,
right?
Um,
and I,
I went into like the sky lounge thing.
Am I going to say the airline?
I always fly,
right?
But I,
I've,
you know,
I finally,
somebody convinced me to fucking,
you know,
go into the Sky Lounge area.
Right?
So I guy and I'll fucking do that.
But then the stupid,
but that thing is fucking stupid because then you have to get to the airport
early to make it worth it.
It's like I don't want to be here.
I want to get here as late as possible.
Immediately get on the plane and get the fuck Outta here.
Right.
So anyways,
I got really,
they're really early to Nashville.
Didn't know that my fucking plane was going to catch on fire.
So I go in there and they'd go,
uh,
I go,
yeah,
I got,
you know,
I don't have my card on me.
And then they go,
you know,
what's your name?
What was the name of your goldfish?
And all of that fucking shit.
And I go through all of that and then she,
she looks up,
she goes,
oh,
here you are.
And um,
I never use miles either.
That's another thing.
I always get miles,
but I've never used them.
Yeah.
Cause I don't want to go on the fucking website and deal with all the,
I just,
well how much does it cost?
I'll write it on this piece of paper and fuck off.
Right.
So she looks in and their eyes just go like,
like biggest sausage.
She goes,
you have 824,000
freaking
gold.
I thought you haven't used your water.
I ain't going on the fucking website that you use miles.
In the past when I first started flying with you two gigs,
then you use them.
When I was making no money,
when I made no fucking money and then we were going to go on vacation and I
wanted to fly first class I would use up.
They would use up all of my miles,
but then once I started making money it's like I don't have to fucking deal with
that anymore.
I hated doing that because I call my travel agents like,
oh,
I'm sorry I can't do that.
You have to log on juice,
go to fucking content.
Nice to fly continental how to Newark all the time.
You'd have to go to apnea.
I,
I'm not good at it.
I fucking hate it.
I would rather,
I would rather just just just
give,
give you the money.
You have to ask our travel person to do it.
Do you know that when I went to meet,
you know when I went to Chicago,
I get over a million to the pilots,
come back and say hello like a they did with George Clooney in that moment.
Maybe I'm getting up there,
you getting up there,
but um,
I got,
I got bumped or something like that.
And so they give a,
they give you the voucher,
like it's a $300 voucher and whenever,
whatever it is,
$300 voucher.
Do you know I took that,
I scanned it and I emailed it to her and I said,
by the way,
I got this voucher so if you can use it towards bills next flight.
And she was like,
oh great.
Actually I can,
I'm like,
so on top of that shit you would have been like,
and it's fucking van.
How many times I got a voucher and a track.
I've never,
no,
I lose it.
I don't even know where it is.
Yeah,
no,
I held my,
some old lady and cat food.
Once again,
this is something that like most people would be like,
oh good,
I can use this.
Towards the next thing and you're just like,
why no ass with it?
I don't know.
Wiping my ass with it and yet,
look how I dress like I live,
but get quarter one dress like Malcolm young on the powerage tour.
Some old white dudes get that reference I just,
I live with within
my fucking means and it affords me an ability to not have to sit.
There you go.
Sure.
All right.
Sorry.
The batteries just died there.
I had to cut this up.
First of all,
you,
you're making it seem like I'm this spoiled rich kid who goes around burning
hunt like lighting $100 bills on fire.
I've always fucking been that way.
I've never,
like when I,
when I wasn't making any fucking money and I was staying at the old show della
super way back in the day,
right?
And they'd always have like the continental breakfast and you've got to get down
here by 10:00 AM and I did it like one time and I'm standing in line with all
these people with these fucking old loafers hoping they're not going to run out
of batter for the welcome waffles.
I'm just sitting there going like,
I can go to Denny's like a gentleman and just sit down and order a fucking
waffle.
I don't need a free fucking waffle.
You know what I mean?
That's like miserly shit to me and get a voucher.
All of that shit.
I'm not,
I'm like on one time I was so fucking mad,
they fucked me over so bad on this plane that I actually did that Old Lady Shit.
And I,
and I walked in and I was like,
I had been waiting and I paid for this and Blah,
Blah Blah and my bag took all this fucking time.
And then they would just like,
all right,
all right.
You know,
you've got to go on the website.
And I was like,
I know what she cause you don't think I'm going to do it.
You know,
I think I'm going to do it.
It went home and I fucking did it and I took all of that time and then there
was,
you know,
they just kept calling,
emailing me back and I kept having a confirmed shit and then I find just set
off,
fuck it.
I just,
I don't have the,
I don't have that fight in me.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't wait for sales or any of that shit if I need it,
I go in and I fucking buy it and whatever it costs me.
If that means I can't do something else in my life,
I just won't do that.
But like you for me,
you cannot put a price on getting that over with as quick as fuck
possible.
Yeah.
No,
I'm giving you a hard time,
but you do have a very healthy attitude about money.
You're really good with money.
You've taught me a lot about being responsible about money,
but I think I have definitely that mentality of taking advantage of little stuff
like that and like,
oh my God,
this costs extra.
Like I have to cut it out.
Even if it does inconvenience me in some way.
Like I just have that,
I am a coupon person,
I am a sale person.
I'm always like,
but it was on sale.
It's discounted.
Like that's,
I love that shit.
Yeah,
it was on sale.
Yeah it was still 700 bucks.
So you go the other way but it was on sale.
I'll leave you your,
your fucking shoes and shit.
All this shit.
That's everything that I buy for the most part is on sale.
I use so many discounted website but it's still expensive as shit.
Yeah,
but it's not as expensive.
Jesus Christ know.
I walk around and like American Airlines is going to give you a free peanut
butter and jelly sandwich cause the fucking pill was 20 minutes late and I'm
like,
hey dude,
you know what?
Keep your fucking sandwich,
uh,
by my own sandwich and you're making me act like I'm a fucking,
you know,
Trump or some shit and you're over there buying like a thousand dollar pair of
shoes.
Do we don't fucking sale
driving nuts with that shit.
All right.
I got to read some of the,
I haven't done any of the advertising.
Let me see something.
And even doing down here this whole time,
Huh?
Listening to the rats and the fucking wall.
Um,
for me,
I just feel like for me,
all right,
was he advertising here?
Here we go.
I will tell you like,
I dunno,
like you know something,
uh,
there,
there's people that I grew up with that were really miserly like that,
you know,
and they didn't,
they didn't leave good tips and they just blahblahblahblahblah and she'd say,
she's fucking paper.
Just give it to them,
make them happy and let's get the fuck out.
But when you don't
have a lot of it,
you have to be miserly.
You have to find a way to like,
sir.
I mean,
you want to have some [inaudible] I moved to New York City,
I ate spaghetti every night.
I had a chair that became a fucking table.
I ate.
I did that all the fucking time.
I can live on fucking nothing.
I did it,
but you know something.
I still had money in the bank as I saved up for my day jobs cause I knew New
York was going to be expensive and I wasn't going to be that fucking guy going,
Oh God,
you know I've done in my last 20 bucks.
How are you down to your last 20 bucks?
How did you get yourself into that fucking situation?
Okay,
I'm talking about white male,
heterosexual.
How to fuck did you get yourself in that situation?
You fucked up.
You fucked up your money.
You're an adult,
right?
So
you know how much money you make and you know what you fucking bills are,
but you know you start making money in for the first half of the month.
You,
you're,
you're walking around acting like you make three times as much and then the end
of the fucking month you're going to come to me and act like a fucking pound
puppy.
Like you're,
you know,
like the world did you wrong?
It's like,
no,
you fucked yourself over.
I believe you guys say you played yourself.
He flinches.
Yeah.
That's why I hate going to the bank at the beginning of the month.
I hate it.
It's a bunch of people whose money is fucked up.
Okay.
And it's depressing to see because they should have been educated on how fucking
money works the first of the month when people get paid and their paydays.
Saturday's the day when the general fucking public goes in there.
Every fucking fifth Carson is in there yelling through that bulletproof glass
and can understand it's,
it's,
it's basic fucking math.
You put 200 in there,
you withdrew 200 so you don't,
you don't have any money left.
I Dunno.
It's very rare that I fucking stick up for the banks,
but when there's fucking people in there,
I mean,
there's all information online.
You know what I mean?
There's all this,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I always had a job.
I have,
I had a paper route since I was in third grade.
And then I had money from my football cards and my candy bars.
I,
I had,
my overhead was fine.
And I remember my friends were always like,
oh,
I'm broke.
Oh fuck a broke.
I'd be like,
get a fucking paper route.
Oh,
I don't want to get up when they go fuck yourself.
It's supposed to feel bad for you because you can't get doubles at lunch.
You got to go to your mother.
How old are you?
Oh,
I mean,
are we ate?
We ate your thought.
Oh,
I'm on my fucking soapbox.
Right.
Everybody should live the way I do.
Enterprising bebe.
I wasn't enterprising.
I just fucking make money and then I always had it and I didn't blow it off.
The idea of you with a paper,
see you had money with for football cards and candies.
The cutest thing I've ever had was the greatest thing.
I love football cards and I used to go down,
I used to ride my bike up to the corner store and I would be,
I would sit there a little freckle faced me going to to two tops.
Football cards come out yet and they'd be like,
no,
I'm sorry.
I would check every single day.
When they came out.
Cue when I came out,
me and all my friends would buy him and then we'd sit there and train them and
stick in the big fucking piece of shit gum that they had that always fucked up
the football card,
usually your best one in the pack and you'd sit there and cut the roof of your
mouth is you're trying to chew it down and we would just sit there and root beer
candy.
Just all fucking sugar.
Yeah.
Just going through.
I got Bob Greasy,
I got Oj Simpson,
I,
Walter Payton,
all these guys were back then.
Randy White,
Jack Lambert,
I still remember all their names.
It was fucking great.
Robert Newhouse,
rest his soul.
Yes.
I used to make like $6 a fucking week.
I was loaded.
Oh,
that's online.
I was fucking loaded.
How old were you when you stare at the paper?
Third Grade.
Third Grade,
and I kept it all the way to like freshmen in high school to the point of like,
you know when the child star,
it's just not cute anymore.
No one wants a six foot paper.
Boy,
I wasn't.
I'm not six feet tall,
but that's just a funny number.
Um,
yeah.
So then,
then I,
then I immediately went from that to then I just had like a,
there was this weird time.
I just didn't,
I didn't have a job cause I was too old to be a paper boy felt.
And then I was,
but I was too young to have a job.
Yeah.
Did you have a job in high school?
Well then there's,
so when I quit my paper route,
I didn't have any fucking money coming in and I was not used to that.
I hadn't dealt with that since I was way back in the second grade.
This was a crisis.
This is my first 2008 that I went through.
So I actually went down,
I think it was to the principal's office and I got a worker's permit that
allowed me to work under rage.
Is that what I did?
Yeah.
To get this job that I wanted.
And during the summertime I used to caddy.
I used to caddy and I used to try to get doubles,
which is two bags and you know,
you'd just be running from one guy to another guy and hopefully,
you know,
it was always really bad but one guy really fucking suck.
But if they both sucked it was brutal.
If one guy slice the other guy hooked and they both were fucking righties that
that was going to be a long afternoon for you.
And um,
yeah I used to do that,
you know,
and it was a couple of live of hearing and the like your childhood stuff that
you did.
I just like,
it's just so funny to me because now I'm pitching.
At first I pictured you little cutie freckle faith with your cards and your
bubble gum and year my orange hair,
I looked like a little fucking,
there's no such thing as an adorable scare crow.
That's what the fuck I look like.
And now you're like a high school kid running around the golf course at two golf
bags on you.
So you literally have worked your entire life.
Then I got this job at this place called more shoe and we were doing the tissue
and it was like,
will I just meant this was the worst fucking job I ever had as far as just like
mind numbingly fucking,
it felt like 20 hours.
It was like a to two hours at the end of every school day.
I take the bus over and then I would fucking walk home like two miles or some
shit like that.
Back when you used to do that as a kid,
just walk along a fucking highway and nobody gave a fuck.
Right.
And uh,
they had like these little cards,
these computer cards with numbers on them.
And you had these order forms and you had these little Manila envelopes.
I still don't know what the fuck it was.
It was something for them to then feed into this computer.
This is like 1984 or some shit.
I hated that job.
Um,
then I,
then I got into warehousing and when I got into warehousing,
then I got my first loan.
My Dad cosigned the loan and I in the car for the car.
Yeah.
But I put all the down payment.
He didn't pay a dime of it.
I bought the whole fuck.
I got a three year loan from Danvers Savings Bank,
one cone and street.
I still remember writing the thing.
It was one 38 63 a month still.
Remember that shit paid that whole fucking thing off.
Uh,
ended up getting another paper route with the truck where I would,
I would drive in the morning and just went back to the paper route.
But I think your foot,
I did the warehousing during the day.
No.
Then I had two jobs and I was also a,
then I got rid of that thing just cause my friends tease me,
Oh,
what are you a fucking paper boy.
And it felt stupid.
It was wait a second extra hundred bucks a week.
Four,
it's huge.
Right?
So I ended up quitting that and um,
the fuck did I go from there?
I tried selling newspaper subscriptions.
What?
Telemarketing type of job.
Yeah,
I had that.
But when I went to college,
I went to college part time and I paid for my education and uh,
all the way to like buy my last year,
uh,
my parents helped me out with that and I also got a loan from another family
friend,
but,
and I paid all of them back.
I paid all of them back before I moved down to New York now.
Then I start,
once I,
when I started doing standup,
I also had a day job
and uh,
and I was still living at home and I was still driving that piece of shit truck
that I bought an 85 red truck.
Right,
right.
And I drove that thing for 10 fucking years.
And I remember when the engine died and I was at work and somebody was going
like,
so now what are you going to do,
Yo,
what are you going to buy?
And I was thinking of buying and I was going to buy like a Toyota Corolla,
just something like a comic car that could,
you know,
go like 200,000 miles.
And I find it was just like,
fuck this man.
I know I want to move to New York.
I could spend like,
you know,
like a new car,
like a Corolla back then was like,
this is early nineties.
It was like,
it was like 12,
11,
12 grand,
which was a ton of fucking money,
especially for me at that time.
And uh,
or I could just spend 1500 bucks and have them rip the engine out and put a new
one in.
So that's what I did.
And I just remember this woman at work,
I've told this story before,
she just said,
she goes,
where's the new car?
They'll be a new car.
Said,
ah,
you know what?
I just,
I just had a new one just putting my truck and sten she just made this face.
He was just like,
that was stupid.
Fucking walked away.
And she was really beautiful too.
And I was just like,
you know what,
it probably was stupid because I guess if I got the new car,
could've bagged you.
I Dunno.
So,
um,
so I had that truck and that,
that was the one like the last,
my first three years of comedy,
I drove around doing that thing.
Uh,
that's when I met Patrice.
He wrote everybody that I knew from back then rode around in that thing.
And then a long story short,
there was an electrical fire and it burned down right before I moved to New
York,
which was fine,
cause having a car in New York is a pain in the ass.
So when I moved down in New York,
I had no debt.
I paid off my student loans.
I had no credit card debt.
I had,
I had got myself out by like 700,
the evolving 700 bucks with the credit card debt.
I just got myself out of it and I didn't buy anything.
I was like,
Jimmy,
the Gent,
take it back.
Don't buy anything.
Don't fucking,
if I could seek any advice to any young person out there,
okay.
When you're young is when they give you those credit cards,
man,
do not fucking rack those.
And if you have,
you've got to knock those,
knock those fucking things down.
Yeah.
Okay.
You know,
figure out what the fuck you want to do before you were involved in some sort of
serious relationship,
which is going to be like,
what?
I want to live here.
Fuck all of that.
Get on the path.
You want to get on.
Eat Your fucking spaghetti in the morning.
You know,
whatever you got.
Whatever you got to fucking do.
If you've got to deliver papers in the fucking morning and all this other shit
to do it,
I don't know.
It's maybe then you too can have fucking nine cell phone numbers.
They may not want to get on the phone.
Can you help me with that?
Can you,
seriously,
you helped me with that.
Can you just can use it?
Can you just like do that for me?
Yes.
I mean,
um,
I can,
I can get through half of it for you,
but then eventually you're just being in the background and when,
when they asked the questions,
yeah,
I will help you do that.
Cause it's ridiculous that you're continuing to pay for that.
That's,
that's what I also thought too because I thought
I signed a contract well on them so I'm worried that they can't get out.
There's always ways to negotiate your ways out of that.
Like I'm,
I'm good at that stuff.
Yeah.
Tell him that I died.
No,
I'm not going to do,
you're taking over the thing because then they'll feel bad.
What can we'll figure it out without telling anybody that you die.
Well,
I'm done for the fucking year as far as gigs.
She want to do that.
Let's,
let's,
let's get rid of those other two.
Yeah.
I want to see what my bill's going to do.
Any like extra shit.
You're paying for it because you don't want to deal.
Yeah,
let's,
let's take care of that place though.
I have a lot of shit like that.
There's other things that I'm in.
When I bought,
when I bought this laptop,
I was just,
they were like,
do you want to take any classes or anything like that and blah blah,
and I signed up for all of them too.
What do you mean?
Like the apple store classes.
So like teach you how to fucking get better at this shit.
God.
Like you were ever actually going to do that?
Nope.
Never even went once.
Oh,
did you tell,
did you tell the listeners how you ordered like 20 of those adapters for your
new iPhone seven know what I did was I was so mad that I ordered five of them
and then they were just like,
yeah,
it's going to be 10 business days.
And I was like,
fuck,
I can't listen to my music for 10 days.
How am I going to get through my workout?
And then the next day I went,
I drove down to the apple store and then they had a bunch of them.
So I said,
fuck it.
And I bought five there and now when I came back I got another five.
So now I've got tenable.
Is what you're married near?
Leave waste of money again,
not a complete waste of money.
All right,
well good.
Well it's a good thing I got advertising here so I can fucking blow it on all my
cell phone numbers and adapters.
All right,
blue apron,
everybody.
Oh Jesus.
Do you ever get hungry?
Sure.
We all do.
For less than $10 per meal,
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes along with the proportion ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals.
Blue Apron knows that when you cook with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals.
So they set the highest quality standards for their community of artisinal
suppliers.
What does our Tizzano mean?
You know what,
I'm not sure mining.
That means you work for yourself.
Family run farms,
fisheries and ranchers.
You're an artist with food,
right?
Whether it's Japanese ramen noodles,
wildcard,
Alaskan Salmon,
heirloom tomatoes,
blue apron.
Is your,
is bringing you the best additional copy points feature as desired?
Well,
if I can skip this shit,
I will.
I was going to say,
I don't think he's supposed to read that part.
Um,
new recipes are created weekly and are not repeated within a year.
I think that's cool.
Choose your meals from a variety of recipes or let blue apron culinary team
surprise you.
Holy Shit.
Um,
customize your recipes each week based on your preferences.
Looking at porch up.
Oh my God.
Choose delivery options to fit your needs.
Oh,
just
I'm going to say it.
Choose delivery options.
The foot fit your needs.
Put it in my,
sorry.
There's no weekly commitment.
There's people out there near,
that's how they want their pork shop delivered.
So you only get deliveries when you want them.
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe and a proportion ingredients and it can be prepared in 40
minutes or less.
Um,
all right.
They wait.
That's like Rachel Ray.
I make 20 minute meals.
Yeah,
I'm just,
I'm sure yet though,
it's all fucking worked out.
You've got 12 ovens in the background.
You fucking asshole.
They always tell you always takes at least an hour to do a Rachel Ray may have,
doesn't it?
Eboo extra virgin olive oil.
She would do that every fucking time.
Why abbreviated?
If you're just going to say it,
Rachel,
I think some of your highlighters leaked in your brain there.
Why are you dragging me into range?
What does she have her do?
Dude,
I said that she was fucking hot way before everybody.
Before she,
she,
she did the j Lo Makeover.
She did the white girl version of it,
you know?
Well,
you know,
j Lo kind of looked like Selena in real life,
right?
Was it just when she was on,
she was one of the fly girls,
right?
Yeah.
And then when,
then when she was going to go mainstream,
they said they lightened her all up.
Right?
Well,
she did the same thing.
What are you talking?
I'm saying she was all Brunette and she was just kind of walking around the
kitchen and no one was paying attention.
And then she,
she,
she liked it.
You got to have the little bit that you've got up the blonde streak in your
hair.
You can't look the same as when you started out as,
when you get famous.
That's why Aerosmith made it because Joe Perry had that little blonde streak in
his hair.
They were looking right past Steven Tyler,
the like,
who is that guy?
We got to sign this band.
That's a true story.
All right.
Check out this week's menu and get your first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/burr.
Uh,
you will love how it feels and tastes to create incredible cook meals with blue
apron.
So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/bird blue apron.com/burr a better way to cook.
All right,
seat Geek.
Oh,
we've got another seating people here.
Last one didn't work out so well.
Let's see how long these people last.
Oh my God,
we're the last people.
I think the Fed's rated them or something.
Something happened.
I don't know.
I can't even tell Siki.
Oh,
these guys are actually not a predatory thing.
These guys are cool.
From what I heard,
buying tickets online for sports and concerts has been a confusing process for a
long time.
It's always been hard to find the best deal for that game or show you want to go
to and none of those older tickets sites want to change that.
But seek geek is different.
They've come along and create an amazing APP and website that makes it easier
than ever for fans to buy and sell tickets.
Seek,
does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites and
ensuring that you get the best possible deal and seek wants to help you get the
most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on Siki seat geek is given a grade based on value.
You'll immediately see any underpriced seats and be able to find the best deals
that fit your budget should ended the KFC.
My stomach's grumbling here,
best of all my listeners get $20 rebate off their first seat geek purchase to
get your $20 rebate on tickets,
download the seat Geek App.
That's an easy say.
Seek the seek app.
Go to the settings tab and click on the add a promo code.
I'm already out at this point.
What do they cost?
I'll pay full price.
Enter Promo Code [inaudible] Seatgeek will send you $20 after you've made your
first ticket purchase.
I would never cashed the check.
Download the seat Geek App and enter Promo Code Bird today.
All right.
Indo Chino.
I'm all right.
Okay.
Indochino is reinventing men's fashion and a made to measure suit is the best
suit you'll ever own.
So suit up,
get a one of a kind made to measure suit,
customize the details you want.
Pick your linings,
lapels,
personalized monogram,
and more.
14 unique measurements.
Go into making a suit that fits you perfectly.
You can't go wrong with the well crafted 100% Merino wool suit.
Um,
and also check.
They're made to measure dress shirts and men successories money back guarantee.
Today my listeners get any premium suit for three 99 that's up to 50% off at
Indochino,
Indochina,
whatever the fuck it is,
I n d o c h Chino,
indochino.com when entering Burt checkout plus shipping is free,
there is no reason not to try your first custom made suit with the deal.
This good in a suit classic from their premium collection will look good,
feel good and less.
That's indochino.com promo code birth for any premium suit for just 399 and free
shipping.
That's $399 by the way.
Indochino your look your way a rate.
I like that.
I like that custom made suit deal for me because I feel like a constant through,
we've got to get you more into that Moby.
You got to get you more doing like what Conor McGregor does,
what?
Knocking people out?
No where he's,
he spends like an insane amount of money of,
what is it,
clothing budget a month do you think?
Oh to it.
I don't.
I mean it looks great.
I'll tell you that now.
He just says all,
let me get a to stamps.com this is the last one.
stamps.com everybody,
some small businesses still thinking expensive postage meter is the only way to
get postage,
uh,
without having to go to the post office.
You know what?
They're raw.
They're fucking wrong man.
The stamps.com with stamps.com you can easily print postage for any letter or
package using gesture,
computer and printer.
Unlike a postage meter,
stamps.com has no longterm contracts.
stamps.com can save you at least 50% compared to a meter.
Like send package tracking information to recipients with one click.
The choice is clear.
Stamps com offers more features at a fraction of the cost.
I had been using stamps.com for years for my show.
Anytime I send out my fucking posters it makes them makes mailing and shipping
really convenient if I can figure it out.
So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name bar to get a four week trial plus
$110 bonus offer,
including the postage and digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage.
Type in burpee you are,
are that stamps.com enter [inaudible] [inaudible] all right.
You want to read some fucking questions here for the week.
Remember when people would order,
remember them.
Remember ma'am,
your CD that people would order emotionally unavailable.
Yup.
And I would help you mail them out.
Yeah,
we go right down to the mailbox,
et cetera.
Yeah,
we'd sit there and like fill out all the little padded envelopes and put them in
there and like you'd be doing like 2040 or something at a time.
We'd go down to mailboxes,
et cetera.
Right.
Like you did it all yourself.
Yup.
Yeah,
that was fun.
It was fun switch you got to do.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Websites,
suggestion.
Sorry about that.
And Yeah,
I just realized this thing's really long.
This podcast has been really long and you sitting there reminiscing.
I was like,
Yep.
I enjoyed that.
That was a wonderful moment that I had with you moving on.
It was in those moments that I knew I wanted to marry you.
All right.
Is that true?
Not,
you know,
some shit.
I don't tell the listeners.
I know when I was going to decide to marry you.
All right.
Yeah.
And they're not going to hear when that one's for us.
Alright.
Websites,
suggestions.
Oh,
I said,
you know,
I'm always go to the same fucking five websites and now that had been kicked off
Facebook unless I give him my fucking passport number.
That's the thing.
This is the thing I'm telling you here.
You always go walk,
you fucking walk.
Did you talk about the whole,
uh,
fingerprint thing?
Oh,
when I bought the car,
yeah.
When I bought my but my Jaguar,
they ask me for that for a thumbprint,
like a fingerprint.
Why the fuck I almost laughed dealership ever.
He was so,
I really wish you guys could have seen this guys face when bill told him now he
was,
he didn't know what to do.
Like he was really,
his brain kind of broke for a minute cause he was just like,
Oh and you're like the,
I'm not giving it to,
what are they not going to sell me the car cause I'm going,
yeah,
no,
of course they're going to take it.
But he was just so used to people being like,
oh okay,
well that's weird.
Okay,
whatever.
And just getting it over with.
And you would just kept being like,
no,
I'm not doing it.
I'm not giving my fingerprints to a car dealership.
And he's like,
no,
no.
It's for your security and this and that and you're just like,
I'm not doing it.
And you were right.
There was like,
there's no reason,
no matter what they say about security,
someone coming in pretending to be,
you know,
when I have fun with them,
I go,
look,
if you could give me,
if you could justify why I'm going to give you my thumbprint,
I'll do it.
And then they sit down,
they say dumb shit like well,
can,
if someone tries to impersonate you and buys the car,
no,
that's not going to fucking happen.
You dealt with like five different people at that dealership.
They know who you are or they're not gonna like it.
No,
it's,
it's insane zone.
Even if I didn't do what I did for a fucking living,
I still wouldn't worry about that.
I'm not,
you don't give you a fucking fingerprints to a car dealership.
These people lie for a living.
What are they going to do with that?
And then we met a woman who was like,
Oh yeah,
they ask you that too.
And she just did it because it was just like,
okay,
there it is.
That's what they asked me.
Now it's out there and he lives up there.
It was like,
I've never had anybody say no to this.
And what did you say?
Oh,
I see.
Yeah.
You'd never met anybody like me before.
I was just talking shit to make you laugh though.
I saw you smile.
It's very hard to get.
You would have though.
I was just talking shit,
I love that.
I was actually very much,
and usually when you get into like difficult BB mode and you aren't just like
giving the other person like the hardest time.
I prefer to say I'm informed,
but go ahead.
Yeah.
Well when you're like unnecessarily giving somebody a hard time who's just
trying to do their job and they're already tired.
Take my fingerprints.
No.
Like when you call up the time life people to order the,
the easy listening set and you're so short and rude to them when they're just
trying to like do their job.
I know,
I know that fucking asshole.
I forget what he asked me for.
They're always trying to upsell.
Yeah,
no,
he was trying to get all this information out of me.
Like all this extra information like you don't like just said to him.
Yeah,
just send me the CDS and the guy goes,
well I can't send you the cds unless you fucking,
there was like some ridiculous thing like my salsa security them that they're
all doing this because they stay sharing the information and information.
Yeah.
And they don't give a fuck what they expose me to as far as identity theft.
So I go,
I'm not fucking do.
And then the guy goes,
this conversation's over.
I go,
yeah,
well then it's over.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I hung up.
I was totally within you.
Always paint me out as a bad guy.
Nia,
my world.
I'm always the victim.
Always the victim that's there.
All right.
Websites,
suggestions.
Cause I was always saying I always go to the exact same website.
All right.
Read it out to God.
Now they've,
uh,
they've also mentioned that you have a reddit sub page and we'd love for you to
do a Ama some death.
No,
they've asked you to do that.
Yeah.
I'm not fucking doing that.
You can't ask me anything.
I'm not fucking sitting there.
Hey Boys,
better douchebag.
I'm going to fucking sit through that for two hours waiting for like one
legitimate question and uh,
hey Billy red balls.
Yeah,
building.
Never going to do an ask me anything I want.
I'm not saying,
never say never.
If I got,
if I got maybe an f is for family,
asked me anything,
I'll do that.
I just don't understand.
Like
I,
they can just go very [inaudible].
You just have to know.
I mean,
or maybe you just have to ignore a lot of like bullshit.
But that's again,
India,
I'm walking by the front desk.
You're not checking or not checking out.
I'm just fucking,
and if that hurts my career,
it hurts my career because I'm not fucking has a genuine question,
Sarah.
Those are few and far between
the world.
The world has a sweaty hand and a really hot armpit.
Right.
I'd be very surprised they gonna put their hand around you when they go to take
the picture and you're going to fill their hand drying off into your shirt and
your other shoulder heating up.
That's what you're going to run into.
And then all the cool people that you really want to talk to are going to be
like,
oh,
I don't want to bother.
I don't want to bother this person.
And they leave.
Those are the people that you want to talk to,
but if not,
let's ask you to do,
what did you do it doing an Ama?
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm in business with them.
If they think it's going to sell the show,
you can't be a dense,
a jerk off move to get in business with somebody.
And then that fucking promoted.
I mean,
look,
if they wanted me to sit on like a Dunkin Stool,
oh,
if I,
if you know what if I could do like that guy drown the clown.
That guy saw years ago on the opiate Anthony Show,
we went to one of those metal fucking festivals and they had this guy who was
called drown the clown.
And this dude just sat there given people shit and he'd make him so mad.
It's like Bull Durham and they couldn't,
he fucking hit it.
And he just had like that Krusty the clown doing that laugh.
I remember.
No,
he would do the laugh.
He would give him shit and make fun of how stupid they are and then they would
miss and he'd be like,
like fucking grabbing three.
He just kept going.
Oh my God.
It was so fucking obnoxious.
And
you just really walking by as,
and I'm going to fat guy,
fat guy.
Hey Fatty,
you ever going to work out you in the purple shirt?
Yeah,
doing that.
And he would just piss them off.
I forget who I was with Donya I'm telling you I'm doing a bad impression of it
cause it was so long ago,
dude,
I was fucking,
I was the combination of crying,
laughing and,
and then also setting,
going like,
is this the greatest street performer I've ever seen in my life?
He was fucking amazing.
Fucking amazing.
I was actually,
I was kind of jealous of the job.
Like I was like,
that's a fucking great job.
Oh my God.
Rest his soul.
[inaudible] magic Patrice in that job.
Oh my God.
People wouldn't want to drown them just so they can hear what the fuck he was
going to say.
And then say he beats you good at it.
Hey,
here we go.
Uh,
barstool sports.
Well barstool sports.
I go to that one.
Uh,
here's one.
www.slashfilm.com and easy to read non snarky movie website.
Okay.
Tumbler.
Hey bill search.
I thought that was a dating site.
Tinder.
Oh,
I'll just say I don't need that with all my cell phone numbers.
If you're into antique cars,
you can uh,
follow accounts that post pictures of classics.
Uh,
use this to follow music,
photography and arts.
It's endless.
And having the APP on your phone is a more stimulating way of killing time
instead of Twitter.
Tumbler is a,
is a good one.
I liked tumbler.
Okay,
cool.
Uh,
yeah by the way,
um,
I'm not the only one who is sick of the same 10 websites to go into.
So if anybody,
you know,
in the future,
if you guys,
uh,
you guys know,
so find some cool websites or whatever,
let me know.
Be Budget,
self promotion here,
Eh,
um,
oh,
well it was the Kardashians.
Thank
you know for me,
for me,
for me.
Dot Com.
I just feel like,
all right,
uh,
last I was saying I was getting into punk rock,
how I kind of miss that and I've always wanted to get into it,
but I just don't know where to go and who's good or whatever.
And,
um,
I doubt I just was watching this rancid video that led me to watch one of the
guitars,
gave an interview and he talked about this one band,
which I already forget the name of something,
something 69.
And they were,
the front man blew me away and I just don't know shit about punk rock.
It always sound to me like I was joking.
Sounds like angry karaoke,
you know what I mean?
Where they weren't quite in tune singing and shit.
And I just read up on all of this stuff and uh,
it just interests me and,
uh,
so people won't tell me bans.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
Punk rock punk rock bands,
obviously the clash of heard of them.
Operation Ivy,
dinosaur junior dead,
Kennedy kings have nothing leftover.
Crack the media,
yours.
Um,
all right,
well,
you know something of the dead Kennedys I listened to.
Okay.
I left a checkout,
you know,
black flag and all these bands like my,
my brothers and my brothers used to listen to the shit and I just couldn't get
into it.
And now I'm,
I'm really finding that I'm liking it,
so I'm definitely gonna check them out.
I'll definitely check out the kings have nothing leftover crack and the media
was because I'd never heard of any of them.
I've heard of dinosaur jr I heard of them too.
I thought that they were more like a,
uh,
like a college man.
Me Too.
Alright.
Nashville,
maybe somebody is fucking with me.
Maybe that's this,
that'd be funny too by the way.
Don,
Donny and Marie.
All right.
Nashville.
Hey there Billy benchmark.
I was at your nine 30 Nashville taping and it was amazing.
I remember every minute of it.
Like it was a Superbowl.
Can't wait till it comes out.
When does it come out?
Are you watching South Park this season?
Go Fuck yourself buddy.
Ah,
thank you.
Yeah,
the nine 30 show,
uh,
was fucking crazy and uh,
I just hope it all comes together.
Well,
I've already looked at some of the pictures and shit and I'm,
I just,
I fucking,
I hate going through the editing process.
You gotta do,
I gotta do it.
All right.
Applause or laughs are you watching South Park?
They ass a brothers said it's,
it's been excellent this season.
I know why you always take the Simpsons.
I love the Simpsons.
Can we tape South Park too?
It's like the best social commentary from his 20 years in a row.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I shouldn't be Washington too.
I completely,
I forget about it.
Okay.
Alright.
Applause or laughs.
Hey Bill,
I was watching one of your older specials because I fucked up and forgot to get
tickets to the one you filmed on Friday.
Uh,
by the way,
congratulations.
I can't wait to see it.
Thank you.
Um,
why is my stomach grumbling the I bought all this fucking night cause we eat.
See?
Yeah.
Which she should not have.
No.
Um,
well I ate so well up to the special,
I kind of went off the rails this weekend,
but starting them off.
I'm getting back into,
all right,
on this particular special,
why do I do this?
I notice a lot of people in the crowd cheering verse laughing.
So here's a simple question while on stage,
what gives you a greater sense of accomplishment?
Laughs or applause.
That's a really good question.
Thanks and fuck those people.
Tell you to fuck yourself.
Um
Huh.
Well laughs usually lab to choose a really interesting question.
Well the applause is an applause break.
He usually got laugh,
goes into an applause.
It's never like you just say something.
If you just say something and nobody laughs and they just applaud,
then you kind of made a statement and that that's like the deuce chill moment.
Like let me,
what they really need to be doing is spending more money on education.
Right?
Yeah.
If you're doing that during a comedy show,
hell tell you that's a rough one.
You know?
Um,
so you'd rather laughter.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm much,
yeah,
I like,
I like when they're laughing.
I will say that,
uh,
applause
is great too,
but sometimes during like a taping,
then that's when it just,
you'll F as a rookie,
you'll feel weird.
Like,
oh my God,
they're clapping and they're all overly amped up cause they know they want you
to have a good special,
so they're clapping and then you don't know what to do.
But they'll always edit around it because they can make it shorter.
So for the comics out there,
don't worry about those moments.
They can also,
if you have a dumb look on your face,
like please stop clapping so I can get to my next show.
They'll just go to a fucking the master shot and they won't see that look on
your face and you'll be fine,
you'll be fine.
Um,
but yeah,
I definitely like,
I like making people laugh to the point that they can't clap.
That's what I would prefer.
Um,
you know,
I of course don't always do that,
but uh,
there are guys out there that I've seen like,
like it's hard for like a Brian Regan level,
funny guy.
When I would watch him live to a,
for the crowd to even be able to applaud because they're laughing so hard.
He's the first guy I ever saw made somebody slumped over.
Like there was an empty chair next to this lady.
I think the other person fucking went,
ran to the back of the room.
He was killing so hard and the woman,
the woman was just fucking,
I like that kind of laugh way you like,
you see when I laugh really hard and if I'm sitting down I get up and I like
runaway because I'm laughing so hard.
I love that kind of law.
That's like,
yeah,
that Apollo laughter.
Cause you know how like black people,
the Apollo,
if they're laughing really hard,
they're like
freaky.
Yes.
Getting out of this seat and just like waving towels and shit.
Like,
yeah,
the whole like hitting each other.
Yeah.
Like,
well we think it's money.
We think it's really fucking.
Yeah.
And when you don't think it's funny,
you really don't think it's funny.
Yeah.
That's what I learned during those rooms.
Black crowds going to have fun with or without you.
So you,
you bet
everything a laugh with you or they're going to laugh at you.
There's no pity.
Laughter.
There's no book he applies now.
We don't do that.
Oh,
some of the fucking hackles I got in those rooms.
The worst is when they would just be talking to each other about how not funny
you work and I forget.
Just go on stage,
just bombing.
It was just dead silence and I just heard this woman in the middle of crowd,
she just goes,
she just looked around and there was,
I left yet.
And there was no,
there was no,
Oh God,
I love black audiences.
There was no magic button because yeah,
there's no pa if you're in the crowd,
in the crowd on stage.
But it's so,
it's so helpful to be a part of it because nobody cares about your feeling.
Oh,
not at all.
Not even.
Not even fucking remotely.
When am I did a black show?
No,
just so like
she was dead.
No,
she was right though.
Whenever I did those shows.
Yeah.
I always felt like in the end,
I,
whenever I did the uptown rooms,
as they call it,
you'd get off stage and you,
you asked yourself one of two questions.
One,
why am I not world famous yet or two,
what the fuck did I ever,
why the fuck did I ever think I shouldn't even be in this business?
Cause it went one way or the other.
You either murdered or you wanted to crawl out of their
talent.
You said this room labar bet on the fucking upper west side.
It was after work,
uh,
black crowd and,
and it was every other fucking time.
Every other time I killed every other time I fucking ate it.
Aw Man.
I,
I saw them fucking,
uh,
Jimmy Mack,
uncle Jimmy Mack rest his soul.
I saw him one time.
He was having a tough team,
was having a tough set.
I think I bombed.
It was just one of those fucking crowds.
They just weren't laughing that week.
Every other week they'd laugh every other week they weren't,
and he was having a tough set.
And I just remember he,
he was bombing so bad.
And this woman was heckled him so bad he had to bring up his career.
He started talking about his imdbs.
Yeah,
I have to,
and he goes,
uh,
front of how he did comic view or something like that.
And like,
he goes,
I don't give a shit.
He's like,
bitch,
I don't give a fuck.
You don't think I'm 40.
You know,
I got a career.
And She just went late.
Uh,
I can't remember how she said,
she said,
Edward,
what career
dressed him down.
I remember I had to go on after it.
And like,
Jimmy was the right,
he was
the fucking man.
I'm just like,
this guy's got 10 years on me.
If he can't handle this fucking crowd,
what's going to happen to me?
And they were just like,
he got off and then I went up.
Talent went up and talent had this,
this tag,
uh,
what he would do,
the worst tag that talent could say after your set was when he would go up.
You'd be like,
come on y'all comedy and easy.
When he said that you were,
the Gao bond was just like,
oh,
fuck.
Right.
So,
uh,
he already did for Jimmy.
Come on y'all comedy eight.
He right.
The only time I ever saw him have to do it for Jimmy because,
uh,
he always killed and then he brought me up to it.
Oh God.
Oh.
I thought about that fucking show for like a month.
Yeah.
I would just think of the shit that people said to me.
I'd be in the shower thinking of it and just,
it would pop into my head and I do that thing.
Ah,
like trying to shout it out.
My head is that they know bill because you always talk about how Heckerling like
is a part of standup comedy right now.
Like Luli it is,
but the thing is though,
I don't know,
maybe I just don't get it,
but I,
I just feel like you don't do that.
You don't fucking heckle.
You let people go up and do their thing and then like,
that's it.
Like you don't heckle people at a play.
You don't,
well I guess people do hackle people at concerts and shit like that sorta,
but for the most part you don't.
Why is it that stand up?
That's what makes stand up awesome.
If this environment where people really feel like they need to interact with you
to that level,
what does your standing there and you're,
you're not given a speech,
you're talking to them.
Okay.
So like,
I think it's that like don't bands get heckled and all that.
I love that.
I bet that to me like,
but you're not,
but you don't want to encourage people to be haggling to a point of disruption.
No,
no.
Like not,
not to that level,
but like,
like those are those,
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
I always thought it was,
it was the most terrifying thing when I started out.
Like,
what am I going to do?
Because you knew it was going to happen.
What am I going to do when I get heckled?
What am I going to say it?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Like what the fuck is going to happen?
And um,
but watching seasoned vets,
handling it,
handling hecklers was,
uh,
okay.
Was like this art form.
It was an art form within the art form.
So and you're real,
you're really good at handling hecklers.
But I can see why some standups wooden would want those people tossed from the
the place cause they're disrupted and this shit and what you're going to spend.
Yeah,
but that's what it's always been at.
What cereal that you're working on?
So hard cry going to heckle bucked up by somebody in their child
in his own standup special.
Okay.
If he didn't whine about it like I don't think else should be okay if,
okay.
The crowd's going to heckle him.
Like what are you,
what are you fucking special?
Like I look every,
every comedian can run this shit the way that they want to run this shit.
But like I look at it,
like I say a lot of fucked up things on stage that are going to make,
you know,
I always fucking give women shit.
Like don't tell they really supposed to just sit there and not say anything.
You know when I go down south I'm always talking.
I'm always fucking around going,
you know when you guys came here,
you took a shit and you're out house.
You came down here and at some point somebody,
somebody getting overnight,
like you lie,
you definitely like to push people's buttons that way.
That's for sure.
Okay.
Yeah cause it's fun.
It's what people did.
You're a provocate tour.
No I'm not.
It's just,
it's breaking balls and then they bust your balls back and then it's funny.
Okay.
Yeah,
I guess I understand that.
I Dunno.
I,
I don't,
I do get annoyed when a,
some people like they'll say like,
do they heckle at a Broadway play?
It's like,
dude,
you're not doing this.
Isn't Broadway that right.
Alright.
Twinkle toes go fucking put on your tap shoes and,
and in a cat suit.
Go do look at it though.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't heckle a Broadway show.
Why you heckle and a comedian.
But you guys,
you know,
go to a Broadway show and somebody Gwalia is fucking jerk off.
What do you do for a living?
That's a good point.
Yeah.
They don't do that either.
Right?
How long is this park has?
I don't want to be torturing people with,
Oh,
who gives a shit at this point?
I got to reach the rest of these things.
All right.
Uh,
getting off heroin.
Oh by the way,
you know,
they will mention all those,
those uh,
you mentioned are all those,
um,
punk rock bands.
I actually found a,
a band that I thought was pretty cool cause I was watching youtube video.
Let me see if I can remember this.
This is,
what do you call it?
What'd you call this kind of music?
Nia.
Trick hop,
trip.
Hop,
trip hop.
I don't know what the fuck the late nineties,
early 2000 [inaudible] this is my college years is all about trip hop BN and
supreme beings of,
of leisure.
Felicia.
It was like them,
it was like port his head.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
What?
Did you just finish that?
Like you knew who the fuck they were.
Now I downloaded this.
It was one of the few times you didn't know who they were and then you just
know,
but you just shy and been like,
you know,
because I'm trying to,
I am,
she's crazy.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
I know what you're doing.
Or you know,
massive attack though,
right?
No.
You know,
Porter said,
I've heard of them.
Yes.
What about sneaker pimps?
Yup.
Yeah.
Okay.
Was there a reason for any of that?
I was assigned.
Were they all sort of like lived in that same,
oh,
okay.
Trip hoppy Electronica.
Let's see what I've downloaded recently.
Supreme Beings of leisure leisure.
Oh I preordered the the pretenders.
New One alone.
Scott,
Jim Kela on drums.
Fucking album.
Sounds crazy man.
Leonard Cohen has a new album and I was listening to some of the songs and I
really,
I love Leonard Cohen though.
Well if you're at two years old,
if you're a pretenders fan,
this is a fucking great album.
I was listening to that shit when I was getting your chicken.
I downloaded Rans Ranson,
I pretenders sing the theme song to Fred Green Day.
Is that them?
I thought I download it.
Didn't fucking transfer.
And then I downloaded that fucking punk band.
Wait Bill,
you know what I downloaded,
cause I was working with t rex,
Todd rex.
We were laughing about that song dream weaver and we were singing it.
So no,
that's dream on,
oh
okay.
You know this song,
right?
Am I got to pay for this?
No.
It's close
this fucking song.
After you did the shit,
like after your day's done,
the thing he didn't want to do when you finally fucking got true,
right?
You take your drug of choice,
you get behind the wheel,
your car,
a job.
You don't do that.
This is,
he's so intense here.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Jessica.
I've heard this song a million times.
I don't know the words.
It's is it?
You know the deal and then it,
then it kicks the fucking drums.
Can we come in?
Right?
Wait,
Whoa,
whoa.
Dre.
Did the pretenders sing the theme to theme song to friends?
Was that them?
Who was that?
What?
Who was it wasn't a kind of a,
no.
All right.
I don't pretend to Chrissy high this week.
If [inaudible] wasn't chick never minds.
How dare you?
Chrissy lives in her own lane though.
I mean,
she did model herself after like rock stars of course,
but like she exists in her own space.
That's,
that was a nice recovery.
If you suggested that she did the fucking friends,
didn't she do like third rock from the side and the real as if she meant that
was her big all.
Oh,
you're a,
you're almost a millennial.
That's like,
that's the new excuse for old people.
I'm fucking with you.
All right,
let's get through here.
Getting off heroin.
Oh,
here's a good one.
Um,
hi bill.
Just wanted to say thank you.
Your podcast is a big reason that I am finally having some success in getting
off the dope.
Thanks.
Ps.
Brotherhood slash TV series equals fantastic.
Uh,
well that's great man.
I don't know what I'm doing to help you get off dope,
but uh,
if you listened to this helps you please keep doing it.
I told you I met American.
You know what it is because he now he doesn't have to take dope cause he listens
to one.
Hey,
I'll be here all week.
They told you I met the scare that told me that he was in a recovery
and that you lessen your comedy and stuff really helped him get him through
because he was having really dark days.
And so it'd be able to laugh is really helpful.
I thought that was amazing.
It is not necessarily funny,
but we'll continue on you.
I've got like three more years.
You're going to fucking read.
Well,
why don't you just save them for Thursday
lady?
Cause you know what?
All Great.
The Great Tea's great that you brought that up.
Fucking um,
a guess who I'm having to as a guest.
Oh,
Joe Rogan.
is he going to bring some elk burgers?
Helped me finally it making his first appearance or first appearance.
You'll be on the Thursday afternoon.
Okay.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
All right,
lady in law school.
All right.
Maybe,
maybe this is for you.
What's up Billy butterballs balls?
Uh,
I'm 27 and a fellow,
a Haka Mark Alum.
I just moved down to a CT from Connecticut.
Okay.
From Boston for law school.
There's this girl who I hit it off with right away.
She's beautiful and we really click,
I find out she had a boyfriend about,
okay.
Uh,
two weeks into school.
Oh,
about two weeks into school and backed off.
But there was little,
still a little subtle hints that she was in to me.
Fast forward to our school Halloween party mid October,
she gets hammered and tells me to man up and make a move.
Me being the sober guy that I am denied her advances because she's still in a
relationship.
The following day she breaks up with a boyfriend and we ended up making out a
couple of days later,
she soberly consider first as her feelings for me to which I affirm my own.
This is going good,
right?
This is all quality.
Everything was above board.
Literally two days later she tells me she doesn't want anything romantically and
needs to focus on herself.
Uh,
no ridge disrespect to the ladies,
but I've been through this shit before.
We're a newly single girl flip flops with their feelings.
I think everybody flip flops when they're newly single.
My question is,
what should I do?
I feel like an idiot for telling her I feel.
And then getting rejected.
You shouldn't.
You shouldn't feel,
yeah,
you are,
man.
You said how you felt
and you were very respectful of those relationship boundaries.
So I don't think you've done anything wrong here.
He said,
on the one hand,
I want to say fuck her,
but on the other hand,
I want to remain friends.
I also literally can't avoid her.
Um,
if you're ever in new haven,
check out the owl.
It's a solid cigar bar looking forward to all your new material coming out.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Um,
I liked the sky.
Yeah.
Here's the deal,
dude.
It's getting,
it's going to take way too much energy to fucking sit there and try and not to
look at her and all of that shit.
So just,
uh,
you know,
you said what she's fucking felt about her.
She's not in that place in her life.
So,
you know,
that's where she's at.
You were both honest.
Just leave it at dad when you see it.
Hey,
how are you?
How are you doing?
I mean,
just keeping it dad.
How was your weekend?
I'll,
that's great.
Just keep it like that and uh,
keep alive,
but don't get sucked into the cause.
Who knows?
She might try to suck you
into the horse.
She's going to,
she feels lonely this weekend.
Course she's going to let them make out.
Oh my God.
Too much back and forth like you,
it's a,
it's a slippery slope,
so don't get sucked back into it.
So be cool.
Don't like ignore her.
Don't be weird but don't.
Yeah,
but you know how women are going to be,
don't try to be friends with this girl and the more he fucking stays though,
don't try to be friends with her.
The more friendly,
the more he fucking does that though.
The more she's gonna fucking one on the,
that's how it works.
If he's just,
if he's just like,
look,
I respect to what you said the other day.
I feel like you're in a very highly emotional state where are going to be flip
flopping and I have to protect myself.
So No,
I'm busy.
You know,
I definitely to be friends with people,
let's just just leave it at that,
that,
that will fucking drive her nuts of course.
And when he,
and she keeps saying no,
she'll end up blowing somebody else in that class just to get back at it.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
Her spiral,
you know I probably shouldn't have said that last shit.
I'm just fucking,
I was trying to be funny but no dude,
you,
Kay,
you went in and look,
I will go out,
wear it.
You got two seconds into knowing that chick.
You want to fucking know her for four seconds.
She want to keep coming back.
I wouldn't.
I would just stay friendly with her and I would leave it at that
but not friends.
There's a difference.
You don't need to be a sounds like an Oprah book friendly but not friends who I
like that.
That's how you get yourself friend zoned as a,
as a male or female doing that thing or like,
oh but we're still friends now.
We're really good friends and we're actually like really good friends and it's
like,
no.
If someone has feelings and someone doesn't or someone has to be linked with
someone's flip flopping,
you can't be friends only with that person because it's uneven.
A friendship is when two people have mutual respect for each other and you're on
the same wavelength.
You can't fully be friends if one is always pining for the other at shit just
doesn't work.
So like at this time in her life,
she,
he can't be friends with her friendly.
What's up?
How you doing?
How's your weekend?
Great.
Boom.
Moving on.
That's it.
He wants to fuck cars.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
We'll let him deal with all of that shit.
We just give out information.
Neither one of course to professionals who want to listen to it.
Not at all.
All right.
Killing it at warehouse job.
Hey Bill.
A while back,
he talked about working at your old warehouse job and going in every day and
killing it.
Well inspired me to seek out one of those jobs and I've been at this job for
about a month and a half.
Let me tell you,
I fucking love it.
The physical work is great.
Unloading trucks and taking big pallets of products to stock with them in the
backroom.
I fucking love that job,
man.
I loved that job I had been doing so in the truck drivers of fucking hilarious.
There's so many like artists and shit that work in warehouses.
Like there's so many people that played in bands and we're just funny.
It was fucking great.
All the suits and the carpet area,
it was terrible.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
uh,
I've been doing so well that one of the leaders told me that my boss was
bragging about me in a meeting with the corporate headquarters.
They even support me in my music and concert photography career as well.
I told you it's always artists out there.
He said,
I photographed Metallica up close and personal here in Minneapolis in August.
I worked my way up to getting 40 hours a week and I'm loving the progress.
Now my question is when you think it's an appropriate time to ask for a raise or
ask about benefits,
uh,
I've only been there a short time,
but I think I proved myself valuable to the company and want to move forward as
quick as I can.
Uh,
we'd like to hear your thoughts.
Thank you for the inspiration.
Well,
it seems to me that you've got this other fucking thing that seems like a way
better job.
If you're taking pictures of Metallica,
isn't that the direction you want to go in?
I mean,
I would use this day job is a way to,
uh,
keep yourself afloat financially until you get your photography business to a
level where you can do that full time and not need to worry about anything else.
But,
uh,
either way,
no matter what she want to do with you life,
you don't kill it for a month and then be like,
hey,
all right,
they,
I did something for you.
Can I do something
for me?
It was going to say I'm in the,
not to be cynical,
but I'm sure they love you now,
but as soon as you asked for more money,
I think that's just going to flip on you real quick.
You gotta be careful they're not your friends.
Wait,
what it is is do you know,
you got to figure out when the review is.
Yeah.
Some places have a six months,
some have a year.
That's when you asked.
You don't dictate your own.
Like this guy's acting like he was like a fucking one month free agent.
Yeah,
don't,
don't mistake.
They're like encouragement for them,
wanting you to now like and while we're at it,
let's give this kid like 10 more dollars an hour like Eh.
Yep.
That is going to,
they'll probably be like,
maybe we can move this guy up for a position or something like that.
So it's all good that they're saying that stuff but yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
I wouldn't play positive but just,
I dunno know,
I breastfeed breastfeeding in public.
Hi.
Yes,
you're Billy Crimson tits.
Let me see the is why I don't do ask me anything cause this is all it's going to
be.
There are so many Billy.
Like when you were on the Simpson,
someone wrote all Billy yellow nips is going to be,
yeah.
Yup.
Let me say.
Cool.
I like it.
I think it's funny.
Let me say congrats on the paths.
Having early season success.
I am from the bay area and we were hoping the giants get into the playoffs again
to when their forth even year world series in a row.
The Bay.
Oh the giant sea a.
Okay.
I see the baseball.
Um,
well this is an old one then knocked down to the plans.
Recently I was traveling through Columbia with my girlfriend.
We were in the airport when we randomly saw a woman breastfeeding her baby just
out in the open and one of the terminal waiting areas.
Uh,
what was weird is as she was doing it,
she was looking around,
making eye contact with everyone who was walking.
By the way,
a dog looks around a park while it unloads a dumped,
my initial reaction was saying to my girlfriend,
Oh man,
that's gross.
She's,
she is breastfeeding.
Apparently this opened the flood gates of feminism.
My girlfriend responded,
why is that gross?
That's hypocritical.
You men love to see boobs.
Uh,
but when it's for you,
when it's for nature's purpose,
you complain.
I then responded,
well,
the ass purposes to shit and men are turned on by a nice ass.
Are Women now going to start taking dumps publicly since that is the buds
primary purpose.
That's a great fucking point.
No,
it isn't.
Yeah,
it is.
She
the same at all.
We were talking about shitting in public cannot be compared to breastfeeding in
public.
They are not the same thing at all.
That is what's called a false equivalency.
Yeah,
I dunno.
It's both.
It's both your,
your,
your ex screening something from your body and people don't want to look at it.
Um,
she responded that there was an obvious difference.
Yeah.
Uh,
since then my girlfriend has been sending me all these pro public breastfeeding
videos of mom's defending the action.
It,
I find it amusing how women all defended and encourage it,
but they know how creepy it is.
So most of them won't actually publicly breastfeed with their own kids.
I explained to my girlfriend that it isn't the rack citing that annoys us
obviously since most of us guys enjoy a nice set.
It's more just the public nature of witnessing a baby drink.
It's dinner off its mother's utters.
Yeah.
He goes,
I felt like a chump because I was having trouble explaining why it's not okay to
publicly breastfeed.
No,
it's okay to do it,
but like you have the right to look at it and be grossed out.
Um,
could you some ammo in this argument and I'm interested in hearing
my favorite
comedian rant about this subject I ever,
the
feeling you just can't mean by difference of opinion.
Can you be an adult being an adult and let me finish reading this.
He's got to put it like he needs ammo in this thing.
Like you just fucking disagree.
It's fine.
Are you done?
Can I use them?
Ammos where can slap my girlfriend upside the head with some facts,
man.
She's a mail fax.
I,
oh you as opposed to what?
Female facts.
Yeah,
we're the ones doing it.
And let me just,
I'm just now I'm just going to,
can I just finish the fucking thing?
No.
Okay.
I'm going to say right now.
Just because you have found that their most women who wouldn't just whip it out
and breastfeed in public and it's the same a lot of women I know wouldn't feel
comfortable doing,
I wouldn't feel comfortable doing it.
I would want to cover myself up.
But if a woman is not covered up,
I support her right.
And doing that.
So just because we wouldn't do it ourselves personally doesn't mean that we're
not going to want it for other people.
Shit happens that kid's hungry.
You don't always have your scarf or your cover up or whatever.
And this kid is screaming and crying and you're stressed out here,
put a tit and its mouth and it will,
it'll be quiet and be fed and move on.
It's not that big of a deal.
You can avert your eyes and keep it moving.
What is the problem?
No,
I'm just saying it's fucking,
it's weird to look at.
It is a little off putting to be like,
oh shit,
she's breastfeeding but like move on,
get over it.
It's literally a second of your life.
That's what he does.
It need ammo.
So then why is this right?
Hey,
take a voicemail India,
take your voice down and don't act like me
in order to come back to his girlfriend with you know these well these pearls.
No,
cause he's young and he thinks he's actually going to change your fucking mind.
Like cause he should have just said,
hey,
fair enough.
Agree to disagree.
Look at,
all he did was he fucking looked at it and he had the natural,
he's natural fucking reaction,
which of course feminist is going to say no man,
that's not the natural reaction that was put into you by the fucking males that
runs to say Dean but Booboo,
booboo and all that fucking shit like this shit the guys do in public.
I am sure that is totally fucking legal.
That is disgusting.
Like when you're adjusting your balls.
Yeah.
Do men even realize when they're doing it,
like sometimes they're just having a conversation with you and they say it's
like tug on their ball.
Some men no more than others.
Some don't.
Some,
you know more than us.
But like here's my thing,
you know,
if they're going to sit there and talk about man spreading like the way we sit
on trains,
but you can fucking whip your titty out and we're supposed to be like,
hey,
you know blah blah and we can't have a comment on that.
You guys is just so fucking,
when I say you guys,
I mean feminists like you guys are just so fucking like looking at shit.
Just one fucking way that it's,
it's,
I dunno like it,
it gets you,
you're doing that classic fucking thing where it starts off,
it's a good cause and then by the end of it you come out the other side.
You're not 100% what the fuck you were fighting,
but you have all like a lot of the same elements of shouting people down,
not wanting to hear the rest of the fucking guys stuff you know you want to be
listened to.
But this guy here is just being honest to how he feels and it makes you feel a
certain type of way over the fuck you say it and then you fucking shout it down.
All right,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You're right.
I did shut it down and I did like cut it off because I was annoyed by it.
But I think what it is is that there's just this,
this feeling of such like,
I don't know.
I feel like the reaction is disproportionate to what they are reacting to.
I feel like a child,
you know,
being fed from its mother,
which is a very natural thing and the reaction that that some men have to it is
so disproportionate.
It's like it's ridiculous.
What is the reaction to the reaction is that he's comparing it to shitting in
public.
That to me is disproportionate to a child
feeding off its mother.
Really think it's like shitty the potluck.
Really?
No,
he doesn't think of it.
That was a clever fucking come back to what she said.
That collaborator.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's dumb.
That just means you don't have a good comeback for,
come on.
You guys play.
You know what?
I'll tell you not to like a fucking feminist to come along and take the suck the
laughter out of the room.
The one asking for ammo about how to deal with this fact that like I enlisted
his,
yeah,
his girlfriend probably when she,
she says spicy.
We did another hour since I turned this fucking thing on.
This is like a fucking two hour podcasts.
It's like the longest one ever.
Oh no,
that's,
that's not good.
That's too long,
right?
People don't want it to be that long.
Yeah,
it's probably too long.
Um,
anyways,
Nia,
the end of the day.
Okay.
Know people have a right to fucking react.
They certainly do.
They do.
Like they look at something that like,
okay,
the same fucking like,
you're not allowed,
you know,
with,
with all of that type of shit that falls on the other side of the fence,
you're not allowed to have your natural reaction to it.
It's automatically considered that there's something fucking wrong with you and
something like that.
There's a lot of fucking like,
here's another thing too.
Like there's those,
there's also light,
but there's also like teenage shades walking around and all of that type of shit
and you're whipping your fucking titty young.
You can't walk around topless.
It's considered indecent exposure in this fucking country.
Right?
Okay.
There's kids walking around,
blah,
blah.
You're pulling out a fucking teddy and then you take a little mini mia,
you and you stick it on the end of it.
But I mean,
yeah,
this is something like very alien about it,
but I'm not the guys.
It's just weird.
I know.
But the thing is we have a right to feel that way.
I'm not saying we're right in what we're thinking shit on Bourbon Street during
Mardi gras and that's not as natural as it is to feed a child.
Not to me,
letting me know.
He says,
Shit,
nobody's a shit on,
on Bourbon Street and Mardi Gras.
When girls are flashing their tits or something like two sem plastic beads made
in China and then it's all good,
then it's like shots for everybody.
No,
but that's what it's like someone's speeding.
They're cheaper.
That's not legal damn airport.
It's not illegal.
But you don't see men being like,
can you believe the way she just led light?
They're,
they're into it,
but a woman is feeding her child at the airport and all of a sudden it's like
shit and public.
No,
because of oppression.
Just,
I can't even fucking give,
I'll get such a great example,
but I can't fucking say it.
Why not?
Yeah.
You're looking at the breasts and the one that just shaking their tits or
whatever.
It's like,
yeah,
okay.
And then all of a sudden there's a baby mom eating off of it.
It's like,
Whoa,
what the fuck to people who don't have babies,
it's weird.
It freaks you out.
Like,
Oh yeah,
that's right.
They also do that.
And it's also kind of fucking weird.
You just sitting there eating a sandwich and then you look down the thing.
I know Nia,
I know the whole fucking world needs to just be like,
oh,
okay,
fuck all our feelings like that.
That's how this,
this shit is going
where it's just you.
Your guys' side is 100% right?
The way you see shit is 100% right.
And a lot of times,
most of the shit you're bitching about,
guys had wrong.
And I agree with it,
but,
but this whole fucking thing that men cannot have fucking opinions.
You guys can tell us how to sit down on a fucking subway.
But we can't have a fucking reaction to look.
I don't give a fuck of a woman.
Breastfeeds I don't.
But like when I see some guy who,
who has a reaction to it and then he gets yelled at like he,
he wants women not to be able to vote anymore.
I just think it's a bit of a fucking overreaction.
Yeah.
I just think that it's interesting that there are certain men who are more
comfortable with seeing breasts sexualized than they are for what they are
sexualized.
Like they're being exploited.
They are more,
they are more accepting of seeing a woman's breasts being use in a sexual manner
than they are for the purpose of what breasts are four,
which is like basically to feed children.
It's not all there or otherwise.
There's not all there for fats like the fat deposit.
No,
that's not all that for,
what do you mean?
That's not all there.
That's for the,
the survival of mankind in that Nice Arac attracted a fucking mail and he comes
over and he bangs Ya.
And then when you guys die,
there's still other people.
There's also that.
Okay.
So in other words for like procreation
does,
there's no way to win this fucking argument because women want to be attractive.
You want attention.
Yeah.
But you want it when you want it.
You want it how you want it.
And you guys have to know exactly when that is or,
and when it isn't.
And if they don't,
if they don't fucking guess,
right.
It's like the end of a Tom cruise movie when he's trying to clip which fucking
wire one's going to blow it up.
The other isn't.
And if you don't 100% no,
when that fucking thing is,
then you are like,
uh,
I don't know what you,
you're the worst fucking person on the planet.
Okay.
So what are you saying?
Just shut up and take it however you get it.
No,
that's not what I'm saying.
Why do you have to go to that level of extreme,
but,
and,
and you're,
you're Tom cruise analogy,
like the rail on the stream.
No,
I'm saying it's just like,
no matter what the fuck we do,
we're wrong.
It's like you want to fucking put on a fucking pushup Bra and have your tits and
everybody's fucking face a wow.
[inaudible] ladies,
we're not paying for drinks tonight.
Right.
You fucking little skirt and barely covering your fucking hoo ha.
Okay.
And then all of a sudden in a blink of a fucking I is,
what the fuck are you looking at?
I'm talking about Dad Shit and you know that shit.
You know what I'm saying?
I know what you're saying,
but I don't know what that has to do with breastfeeding and any of that kind of
stuff.
Cause that's not what we're talking about.
Well you let it into the whole thing like you know,
you,
you'll,
you'll look at like sexualize breasts were off.
It always comes steering around the,
somehow men
are acceptable,
but somehow child being fed off of leg of the breath and I don't understand why
that is.
Why that's more comfortable.
She's not a man's,
it'd be to be like not a man.
Well then fine.
Maybe that's what it is.
But like that's something that I feel like people need to get over.
I would not breastfeed in public without being covered.
But if a woman needs to do it,
I get it.
And it shouldn't.
I think people could just submit what they think.
I think people could just think what they think.
I think he,
I don't feel that the way I look at the way that they think and progress a
little bit.
That's how we get to find a little bit more understanding between the sexist.
So we don't have the yeah,
but you know how that works.
So every year argument like we're not getting anywhere.
I don't understand.
Cause you know how that works,
that progressing thing works.
The only way this progression in it is if men see the world the way women want
them to see the world.
That that is the so called progression between the sexist right now that's
what's fucking annoying because all of my shit is just considered ignorant and
not valid.
And I'm a caveman and all of your shit is applause.
Break,
talk,
show shit 100% and women can literally do exactly to men what the fuck they
don't want done to them in different ways.
And it's just,
and it always,
if a,
if,
if a guy gets completely fucked over by a woman,
what do they say?
Well,
he picked her shouldn't have married her,
you know what I mean?
Do you guys aren't necessarily held accountable for your actions when you picked
a bad dude?
If you pick a bad guy and he's a fucking piece of shit,
then it's,
you know,
not only not your fault,
it's the guy's fault and it's all men's.
Then all men have to sit down and listen to a fucking lecture or read a sign on
a fucking subway.
Like we're all walking around dragging women down the street by the fucking
hair.
But there's no signs on the subway or anywhere else about the fucked up behavior
that a lot of women display with men.
Okay.
So that I can accept that.
Okay,
so that's all I'm saying.
So this is another fucking thing where it's like your guys' reaction literally
to how men sit on the fucking subway is 100% validated.
I can't be like,
listen,
I got balls.
I don't want to smash him between my thighs.
Fucking get over it.
I don't,
I don't have that option.
You can be like,
well fuck you,
I got to breastfeed my kid.
Get over it the way you look at it as fucked up,
but our whole shit is,
we have to be like,
oh really?
Is this,
is this,
is this issue?
9,863 of this fucking month that bothered you.
You guys are these faultless fucking human beings.
Like I said,
near most of that feminist shit.
I fucking agree with it,
but like it's just every fucking day now.
Every day now there's some new fucking thing.
It's a fucking lecture.
It's seeped into the comedy clubs,
everything.
It's just so fucking precious now.
Stupid.
Well,
I know correctness is
like across the board is like can be,
I'm going to start it out like nine hours of the shift.
The enemy of like creativity and stuff like that.
I definitely agree with that.
It's childish,
but I just feel like when it comes,
I just
yet another thing.
It's heart was in the right place,
but it's solves absolutely nothing.
No,
I understand that.
But all you did was you gave,
you gave truly horrible people a roadmap of words where they can navigate from
one side of the river to the other and still have their fucking job.
But what's in their heart is still in their fucking heart,
but they can say native American,
African American,
uh,
um,
whatever,
whatever the fuck you supposed to say.
Post post person,
melt person it shit.
It's just fucking annoying to be like,
hey gimme some ammo so I can tell my girlfriend why women shouldn't breastfeed
in public.
Like that just sounds like some ignorant shit to me.
It sounds to me like he's losing the argument and she's probably affecting the
mood of the fucking,
he's too dumb to just let it go cause he's young.
That's what he's doing and I imagine right now that she's probably using sex is
the lack of sex or whatever to now punish him and now he's walking around like a
fucking little puppy that gets slapped on the snout with a fucking newspaper.
Like a lot of guys in relationships,
people that are just modest about that kind of stuff.
I had a friend over not too long ago and she brought her six month old with her
and she had to breastfeed him and when he was off the thing,
you know when he would drink some and then he'd be sort of like looking around,
she was like covering her boob and it was just her and I in there and there was
a part of me that wanted to be like,
you don't have to like cover your breasts in front of me.
But that was a natural,
I'm not arguing his thing.
I don't give a shit of women breastfeed in public.
I don't give a shit.
I'm just saying that there are women who are,
and I'm sure the reason why she was looking around like,
you know a dog taking a shit is because she's thinking,
Oh God,
who's going to judge me?
Who's going to judge me when she should?
In an ideal,
perfect world,
just be there with her baby if she gets off on a beating and then just why she
is saying the ca you just said that.
Oh my God.
Oh my God is gonna Judge me.
She lives.
Oh cause she was saying he was,
he was saying that she was looking around when she was on Columbia.
She lives in Colombia.
Who knows what the culture is down there,
what the opinion is.
I don't know shit about Columbia.
Do you know,
why would you watch narcos and all of a sudden you know what these fucking
people are thinking now.
I would never try to speak for Columbia.
I have no fucking idea what they think they might.
It just might not be.
That might be totally fucking normal.
And she was just people watching or she might've been a freak and she was trying
to see if any,
but you know she's Alexa submission is,
who knows what the fuck she was thinking.
She was probably like,
oh Jesus Christ per people looking at me like I'm crazy because I'm
breastfeeding without a cover.
She's probably really like having some sort of anxiety about it.
I bet it's probably socially acceptable.
So that's what I would guess.
So she's just fucking looking around.
Okay.
Yeah.
She just looking around
near we got to end this fucking thing.
This is like Tupac.
Just,
all right.
Sorry guys.
I know this was really long,
but,
uh,
we hadn't seen each other for a while.
We like to talk.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll see you on Thursday.